[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's all come down to this with eleven
grueling games behind them the two best
players on the planet will face off in
an electrifying final showdown that
could decide who will wake up tomorrow
as the World Chess Champion will the
reigning number one retain the crown or
will the challenge arise and steal the
throne game 12 live from London coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to world
championship edition of today in chess
and what a day it is for the chess world
we are in the final round of the World
Chess Championship our American
challenger Fabiano Carolina facing off
against the reigning king Magnus Carlsen
and we have five and a half points for
both men the top two chess players in
the world and there we've reached the
finish line
Wow what a couple weeks it's has been
and it all comes down to today yes I'm
Jennifer Sajadi here with Grandmaster
Yasir Sara Juan yes it does 11 games 11
draws this is the twelfth and final game
in the classical world chess
championship
whoever wins today is the world chess
champion wow I'm gonna be in the edge of
my seat throughout the the broadcast yes
because and I'm predicting a thrilling
contest no doubt so let's take a look at
the results after 11 rounds we have had
11 straight draws that said today is a
very special day and fabi's starting to
get a lot with white so I'm that doesn't
mean the today's gonna be a drop right
anything could happen today but if it is
a draw we have six six at the end of
these twelve hard-fought games we will
have tie breaks on Wednesday November
28th so we're gonna have a World
Championship but before December yes a
world champion that is for sure and as
you say fabbi has white today and here's
the format this is the end of a best of
12 games that's why that magic number
six and a half points both players with
five and a half points today
and we drew up a three part time control
prize one of over a million euros but
I'll interrupt myself because it looks
like we do have moves in the game has
hotly debated in the chess world is it
gonna be a Sicilian or is Maggie going
to revert to the double King pawn
considering that five he got so much
with white in the last two White's
he had absolutely he has gotten a lot
against the Sicilian and surprisingly
enough
Magnus repeated the same lame that he's
been playing throughout the match now
fabbi in the first three games that he
was white played Bishop b5 transposing
into what we call the Rasul emo but in
the last two games the ones you've
mentioned he has essayed the open
Sicilian and the players have quickly
gotten themselves into what we call the
sveshnikov defense after E 5 this has
been the last two games and in fact we
do have they've repeated everything
exactly up to this moment Knight d5 big
threat of a fork on the c7 square
there's a trade takes now in the
previous two games that he was black
Magnus played the main move Knight b8
that is to say he retreated his knight
from c6 to the b8 squared today he's
made a little bit of a twist it's a well
known move it's highly regarded as well
but he's for the first time he's played
knight on c6 to e7 gotcha yeah because
of course after die PA we saw those a4
games in which Bobby he really got a lot
in both contests that's right that said
there were a lot of people who thought
that Magnus would still repeat the
Sicily and don't forget that in game 10
despite the fact that Magnus wasn't
prepared and had to burn a lot of clock
time he was actually the one with the
most winning winning chances in a sense
he was the one studying all the traps
exactly so clearly what the signals to
me is Magnus is not thinking about you
know trying to grovel for a draw like he
is looking for his chances knowing
knowing 100% that fabi's gonna be
looking for his own yeah but let's go to
Grand Master Maurice Ashley because he
has some thoughts on how this context
how this contest could impact the
history of chess absolutely as you guys
mentioned there's a lot of stress on
both these players because they
understand that this is a gigantic
opportunity and once you let go of the
rope you may not see it again at least
not for a while
first of all let's took it let's take a
look at the world champions issue that
is Magnus he knows this fact he's a
student of history in the post World War
2 era since fidei began organizing the
World Chess Championship match
only one counted one undisputed world
champion has ever regained the title
once losing it and that was Mikhail
Botvinnik and he was seated into the
rematches so he did not have to go
through the gauntlet gauntlet of
candidate tournaments in order to once
again try to get the title back Magnus
knows how hard it is to try to get there
again so he doesn't want to see this
that at all he doesn't want to hear and
he wants to win this match maybe today
or at least in the tiebreak but take a
look at the challenges road ahead as
well only two undisputed world champions
have won their title after a previous
failed attempt that is you go through
the candidates you finally get there you
lose and then you have to do it all over
again well Spassky was able to Reema
knew where those waters and get back
after losing to Petrosian in 66 he won
in 1969 and uh none after Loosli
Kasparov in 1995 it took him a dozen
years before he finally got the title in
his hands that is as undisputed world
champion this is not easy this is a big
moment opportunity comes once in a
lifetime well sometimes twice but it's
not an easy road and that's why and that
is why the players are feeling so much
stress right now and they will have to
handle their nerves as this is an
exciting start beautiful opening as far
as the commentators are concerned I'm
sure the fans as well Thank You Maurice
indeed as far as the commentators are
concerned and especially as far as the
guests are concerned to Jennifer that's
right yesterday I mean two days ago we
didn't have the most thrilling start to
the game or finish to the game and what
you're bringing garry kasparov back and
boy what two days have changed this is
exactly the type of position you want to
ask Gary about but the news gets even
better after that we're gonna have
Vladimir Kramnik yes it's gonna be so
much fun to just sit back and hear what
true greats have to say about the game
today I'd only that Vladimir Kramnik is
quite a specialist in his own right in
the special car having won some really
really wonderful games on the black side
so it's nice to have them oh I mean we
couldn't ask for a better line up I just
wanted to show what happened in the game
it takes to eat 5e takes d5 and let me
stress the fact that I'm not a major
efore player or for that matter
especially a cough player I do know a
little bit about this line after the
retreat in 97 we saw the move c4
obviously white is reinforcing his pawn
on d5 sometimes he wants to play c5 but
at the same time white is laying a
really nasty trick if you're not paying
attention and you make a very bad move
for example like g6 you're lost on the
spot like lost Queen a4 with the threat
yes you can the threat was this
discovered check and mate well here we
just have a smother I thought we'd have
some key moments but I didn't so after
c4 this move Queen a 4 is a massive
threat the knight must move now I'm more
familiar with Knight f5 I thought that
this was the line that everybody plays
the idea behind Knight f5 is as simple
as it looks you're going to play one day
in the near future a 7 a 6 driving this
night away and this night ends up on the
d4 square but that was not the choice of
Magnus Carlsen he played Knight g6 and
very surprising to me came the move
Queen 8 4 I'm certain we're still in
there playing yeah and again the threat
of a double check either by 96 or 97
double check for king king and rook
forces Bishop d7 let me boldly state the
obvious Queen d7 would be anna rendus
mistake because after 97 check King
moves yeah these are all easy wins for
Bobby so you have to as black play
Bishop d7 and now we've seen before and
okay sure about five was Maggie's
response so Bishop f5 so obviously um
obviously I mean he was playing with the
black pieces and his confident his foot
skills but he's not worried about Queen
a for allowing Bishop d7 that is true
Queen a for Bishop d7 would be a
repetition well I've got a turn no but a
pretty quick a pretty quick reply by me
by the way H for triage for dreaming
wrath via harass Knight age four is
off-limits because because of Burke
tanks age four and then ninety seven
check right you've got to keep the Queen
would be overloaded exactly so instead
of Maggie
um immediately by the way it plays they
tried H five nearly stolen his prep
right absolutely
a little less clear he seems like he
spent a little bit of time so what I
think it was with Magnus of course had
this position on his board last night
Fabia will probably one of a hundred
different some variations he looked at
your whatever you want I'm sure he was
looking at ninety eight ninety percent
of the time and then maybe spending some
time on e5 as well double King pawn as
well so it's probably spending a little
time on everything
exactly yeah the split his time a little
bit bit so that's what I think this
signifies a five Ianno has seen this but
it's not like crystal crystal clear so
he's trying to recall some of the
variations and stuff like that
absolutely well Maurice bring us up to
date on what what's the opening theory
have to say about this fascinating line
Maurice and our guest later Vladimir
Kramnik will absolutely be relevant to
this contest as they are following a
game of his from Batumi the Olympian
that just finished where he was on the
white side of this position as opposed
to the black side how much of a surprise
is that but let's first go through the
niceties of this position here of course
ninety eight played more often in this
position all the two and a half times
more
ninety-seven by 97 also a popular
subversion c4 the main move played here
as mentioned to play this idea and then
the movement Knight to g6 not as popular
as night at five but definitely often
played as well it is part of the theory
Queen a Ford the third most popular over
this position bishops normally move here
first Bishop d7 necessary as you
mentioned Queen before the most popular
move in this position and now Queen b8
is the standard move we're an eighth
most often played most natural only
three times do we find this move a
versus 42 for Queen b8 only three times
when we find Bishop f5 in the database
so digging deep down is Magnus down into
the the not so not so a traveled waters
to find a move like Bishop a5 you would
think that that one may have escaped
Fabiano's notice but remember Bobby was
playing in Batumi as well so this line
he must have seen an h4 was Kramnik
choice in that game and I'm gonna pull
up the game for us against we're gonna
[ __ ] in in the Russia Serbia match
there and here is where the novelty
arises h4 is intending to play the move
8 h5 in that game a 6 was played a 6 was
the move plane and it was responded to
immediately by age 5 but Magnus has
thrown in his wrinkle he said no I'm
gonna play this one first so you don't
get your play on the Kings side now I'm
going to play a 6 and chase you back
what do you really have in this position
so we are now in New Order's Magnus's
novelty h5 on the board and we'll see
whether or not a response has been made
as yet no it hasn't it looks like h5
counts the opening novelty anyway to
Magnus and Fabiano did not prepare this
position before the game we have to
assume as he's stopping to think now for
some time this new wrinkle will it
matter that much this move played on the
board clearly Magnus had prepared it
must be feeling good about himself
absolutely he's feeling good about
himself well
I actually see both sides I'm trying to
be objective here about the position
itself of course I like it when yeah it
shows the checkmates or father right but
as for the position I can see both sides
because let's be clear hold on wait wait
wait wait wait wait
fabbi is the one been dropping novelty
yes okay
I mean seriously I'm good yeah in in the
previous games that he's been white
especially be for Bishop d2 a 485 stop
and this is the first time and I can't
even remember how long in this match
that Magnus is the one making a novelty
right so you feel good about that
well no I'm just saying it is what it is
assuming that's good for that that's
good for his chances in this game for
Magnus is chances yeah I'm just saying
that Abby hasn't been the one who's been
dictating in this match from the
openings he's been getting his novelties
his preparation on the board
and this shows something like h5 but the
question I had Marie says when you're
looking at this position objectively for
a moment you see this knight on b5 in
this Queen on before and it looks kind
of I want to say amateurish I mean this
is nothing really behind it that the
Queen looks a little bit off sides and
then you're combining it with the move
age for which you know you're doing
everything on the Queen side and
suddenly you strike out on the Kings
side with h4 it it feels disunited to me
but is there a harmony according to the
engine does the engine like this
approach for white it looks good it
looks just coordinate for what white
okay to play Queen a 495 Queen B for now
you've got all your all your pieces gang
ganging up on the Queen side and
suddenly it you toss upon out over here
on h4 and you go huh why is this good
for white well it's fine for white and a
slight edge for white in fact it does it
does it already likes White's position
okay I think some primarily because of
these pawns
in the middle of the board h4 as I'm
letting it run h4 is stock fishes first
move okay
first response is to disturb the
position of this knight on g6 and get
this pawn going down the board and I
have to tell you in the age of engines
we've seen the pawns that we thought had
to stay back particularly it started
with G pawns but you know guys like Paul
Kerry's and the carries attack show it a
long time ago you can put your G pawns
in the Sicilian so we're going on where
we go back into the 50s mm-hmm but these
days now the H pawns have risen and you
see I remember listen to Elektra by
Matthew Sadler about the fact that he's
using alpha zero to inspect all these
games and he's come to see how alpha
zero loves pushing its H pawns now try
to tell a beginner that you're teaching
yes you should be pushing your H pawn
early in a chess game I mean we slapped
the hands of our students when they
start pushing H pawns I think under
start playing one H for now as an
opening every night the fact is H pawns
now get pushed regularly I saw I saw
Wesley so win a game in the Olympian as
a matter of fact playing the sicilian
similar type setup and throwing out h
for early and like what does h for i
have to do with this position at all
these H pawns get thrown down the board
all the time these days now we saw a
Rob's into it as well in the u.s.
championship here so H for threatening
to dislodge with H 5 and now the move h
5 stopping that completely and now we
also the challenge to me though is black
wants to play a5 normally eventually
right this bone in h 5 doesn't harmonize
with this pawn sitting on f7 and pushing
you're gonna give up this square so is
this going to be fluid the way this
position will continue from this moment
forward not so easy
also this night can be dominated so for
example to move like g3 in this position
where is this Knights future you don't
have to push this pawn forward you do
weaken some light squares but when you
push your also weakening some dark twist
as well
this is absolutely double-edged and
we've noticed Magnus no matter what he
loves the double-edged positions with
black he's been just going after them
even though he's got in worse position
it looks like he doesn't mind playing
double-edged Affairs against Fabi and
he's repeating it again in this game I
love it I mean the issue for me is that
you know Maurice mentioned alpha 0 and
alpha 0 really like this 95 move that
was something that Matthew Sadler that
he wrote an article on chess 24 with
Natasha Reagan right and I think I got
that name right but I'll double check it
and they had analyzed these first 8
games without the zero and they pointed
out that 95 is in the opening in the
session of Cobb is considered very
favorable by alpha zero right so my
point is when you were talking about the
pieces of Bobby not harmonizing I
actually thought you were talking about
black at first yeah it's like you know
the knight on g6 and the bishop on f5 it
doesn't look very fast and coffee to me
and and it's true yeah because just as
Murray so say you want to play exactly
you put your bishop in the way and the
knight on g6 is a little bit off sides
too and so forth and so on but again
we're reckoning that the computer likes
just this wedge of pawns in the center
c-45 as its reasons for giving white
such an edge also yeah now the crazy
part is that in these particular lines
of the special knock off which we've
seen in the previous two games where
fabbi was white it's it's boiled down to
a situation where White's plays on the
Queen side
he's been playing d4 and a 4 and C 5 and
you know let's go and black has been
playing f5 f4 and attacking on the King
side now the inclusion of these two
moves h4 and h5 well it's gonna make it
quite awkward for the players to be cast
thinking sight I can see just as Maurice
is saying that after a move like g2 g3
and maybe Bishop e2 it's not going to be
so easy for black to get pink side
castle not to mention the fact that we
can throw in the move Bishop c5 at any
moment and g5 is also one of those
annoying those should be 7 and you can't
really play takes because the d6 pawn
will be
under my so likely to induce a 7f 6
which means cackling even less palpable
right I mean all I mean both sides are
bummed out that their kings are not
going to have safe bunkers we need four
yes it's on the board
Queen a4 played and Bishop d7 what
Bishop f5 right oh well maybe he's just
trying to save a move because he
anticipate that I'll move 40 I mean he's
gonna be more likely to be on time
pressure so he might just be trying to
but the question for maggot Magnus okay
instantly instant classic people oh and
I love the way he's playing this opening
this is giving the fans a lot a lot to
look forward to sure about but that said
this were ending to the match that
Maurice is kind of alluding to Bishop DS
anymore we've seen the move Queen a4 is
that right Maurice or Bishop d7 are we
so we've seen a repetition right before
and Queen before has already been played
oh my wait because does this Fabi have
any other does Magnus Magnus doesn't
have any other options besides Bishop f5
that we're good right or could could you
switch it up how it's not so easy
because if you play for example Bishop
g4 after all you don't want to really be
in front of the pond and this move
Bishop d3 could good don't forget I can
play Bishop e5 in interpellation first
exactly five and then Bishop d3
yeah you've already played FX exactly
something like this you know oh you're
making very good point Joe and that just
looks like an out out in out refutation
because now Bishop d3 and as you're
pointing out you can't move the knight
the night
step back because d6 pawn is hanging so
Bishop f5 is actually forced so so
basically if I be pleased Queen a4 it's
done right he could make a draw no no no
no because Bishop f5 came when the pawns
were still on eight right right right
right right okay gotcha so he would need
to play it twice so what do you think is
the reason for this repetition work no
but after Queen a for Bishop d7 then he
play Queen before so this is kind of the
moment cuz after Queen a for Bishop d7
is there a better way before appears
twice because h4 h5 is in place right
before but I've only appeared twice
right so it's still got she's still not
there you hold on just to include the
whole audience into our discussion in
chess when the position repeats itself
exactly the same three times in a row or
it's retirement issue we call it the
game is a draw and either player can
claim the draw by repetition and what we
have been seeing is that white has
played this move Queen a4 with this
deadly threat of a discover check the
that threat got Balad the bishop
retreated Magnus's Bishop retreated
stopping the threat of Knight takes d6
double check ABI has played Queen before
again clean before okay yeah so if he
does play Queen a for again and after
Bishop d7 wait before the second time
right h4 hmm unless my board is not
update for h5 and then okay h4 h5 that's
one that's one situation where the right
yeah the queries on d4 the Queen's on d4
so Queen a for Bishop d7 so that's two
yeah what's 201 for this but he hasn't
pleased me before yet this is the first
time this will have been seen right so
now Queen before so this is the second
time that we've seen this position yeah
and this position yeah also second time
what I'm saying it was quite weird a
favor
if we were to play commune a for it
would be the second time with Queen a4
but then after Bishop d7 in the Queen
you couldn't play Queen before we'd have
to find something else right which
doesn't seem right I mean it seems like
Queen before is the best move after
Bishop e7 so Fabi wants to do something
else
he'll do it now right and you could also
in this was a queen a3 I believe is it
way to play so you could go into other
lines as well but I don't think Bobby is
going to just not repeat for the sake of
changing up the position because he has
not prepared that position at all the
problem for him is dealing with this
novelty he knows that Magnus has
prepared it right and if he's it's
either he continues along this line
right now or he just repeats and says
that's it I don't want to see this
position at all that would be an
incredible concession on his part of
victory for Magnus and I think people
would be howling from London all the way
to Mumbai and watching this and saying
is this how you wait your chest ornament
chess match a quick easy repetition like
this in game 12 that would be incredible
where all the marbles for all the
marking think he's going we saw so many
nice work
we should note though we saw something
similar in New York that's gained 12
Magnus with the white pieces play at an
anaemic opening line and quickly just
shut everything down and said I want to
see the tiebreak now Magnus does not
because he was favored in the tiebreak
though not as much in that one because
he was playing in scar yakin as he would
be considered in this one and Fabi
doesn't have the the same kind of
historical record as car yak and in a
world format world blitz champion after
all so for Fabi to say I'd rather see
the tiebreak then the preparation here
that must be just his heart beating in
his chest right now trying to make that
decision
what does Maggie does Magnus I never
called him Maggie I don't know I've
prepared in this
position that would make you avoid it
completely you got the white pieces with
a spatial advantage the guy plays one
new move and you run yeah I don't think
he's gonna do it oh no way I US chess
puts it well when it tweets please don't
repeat please don't repeat nothing can
go wrong man per me fuh happy doesn't
repeat because he has a really good move
Maurice what is that really good move
well I was checking some lines with the
engine just playing around horsing
around it engine does like the move
Bishop to g5 of course f6 is such a
major concession engines go nuts thank
you very much for that move this would
be 7 the capture will occur on e7 you
have to take back with your king because
your paw is hanging so best is simply
Queen to b8 white still has a simple
edge here after the move g3
controlling that night on g6 at any
moment preparing to bring this piece
back after a 6
you drop your knight back no problem now
check out this line Bishop to e7 in this
position takes on e7 King takes 187 King
takes that's right
c5 yeah you want to try something like
this we don't care let's keep playing
chess you got me in the middle I got
development you want to go for a
position like that that's ok
black is doing just fine in a position
like this even sacrificing pawns if
that's what Robbie is looking at oh he's
mmm these are pawns I don't want to take
the line I'm not sure I want to go into
when the guy is better prepared than I
am so he'll be facing this challenge as
their original ways to play with the
black pieces that creates some trouble
and as you're sitting there calculating
it you're going
he's already looked at all of it the
same issue that Magnus has had against
Fabi many times during this same match
he didn't make the repetition by the way
and surprisingly enough he didn't throw
when Bishop g5 which looked like the
more aggressive move he has played
Bishop e3 at once
and sorry Maurice are the players would
even without the repetition are they
still in there in theoretical waters and
in other words oh5 actually was already
the novelty sorry I stand correct my
self we've seen age five so Bishop III I
see that yet actually I'm not sure it's
on the live board yet okay yeah me too
for a second but then I'm seeing
something else so I'm not sure let's get
confirmation or what the moves are okay
we'll wait for that but yeah I'd say
Bishop would that be a good move with
that well it does attack a7 and it just
sets up I just can't believe he's gonna
repeat yeah I just can't believe it
because I feel like he's white and it
just doesn't seem likely to me and it's
a very common psychological trick then
you repeat once I think it's like
recommended in the rescues box well I
think like a good the Soviets don't they
recommend you repeat wants for two
reasons especially if you're under the
time and the clock like Fabi is a it
might not seem important now but it's
kind of like investing in your 401k
doesn't matter now but 4:20 linnaeus
2030 moves down the line or 20 30 years
down the line suddenly about that extra
move that you snuck in might mean
something exactly was played Oh ceci has
it on its screen I checked over and
another board and Bishop III is on the
board and the second thing is you
psychologically tell your opponent I'm
gonna make you tell me that you want to
repeat moves right so there's like a two
part reason for doing that so
I couldn't imagine I don't be such a as
Murray said such a psychological
concession hmm I think to me it feels
like you prepared this line your
opponent surprised you but you're still
white and you're the number cue chess
player in the world just neck-and-neck
with number one it would be too much of
a statement I think to sure and I
understand all of those that all of that
reasoning seriously but the thing that I
think is the real problem for Fabiana
I really don't think he should be
playing a tiebreaker I really think he's
a very serious underdog and I think he
actually has to risk and play on with at
the white pieces so I'm very happy to
see the move Bishop III not because of
the psychological and things like that I
think he just has to win here and now
right though combined I think yeah
absolutely
yeah and Maurice what about Bishop III
no such sharp such a sharp position to
have to play if you are white you
haven't seen it ever but at least the
main line with Bishop g5 he's avoided
for the moment and that is most likely
what Magnus really concerned himself
with in his own analysis so practical
reason Bishop g5 is the sharpest move
obviously let me just get this position
this is the live board Bishop to e3 Z is
the Bishop to g5 is the most pressing
move not necessarily the most obvious
but the most pressing move why Bishop to
e3 might be the most natural move just
develop a piece and keep things going
Magnus did not take that long and he's
played the principles move a six on the
board right now we expect to see the
move Knight to c3 and again the engines
don't care about pawns here Bishop to e7
saying you can have a be pawn if you
like now if you defend this pawn it gets
even more curious black is in SU the
castle you want this [ __ ] sorry Bishop
to e2 could then get played and then
this pawn starts to hang and black will
say you want this pawn efore take it you
can have it takes Knight in Bishop back
to deal with these threats
well maybe we go after some some play
with Bishop to g4 is what the engines
are getting immediately sacrificing
material like you go right ahead
this is going to be fine for black in
the long run so sharp chess by black
trying to prove that white spatial
advantage is pretty much irrelevant in
this kind of position and this Queen is
just floating because it really wants to
take this pawn but it really doesn't
want to take the part because of the
tactics immediately along the B line and
Plus black is looking at pressure also
difficult to Castle because sacrifices
on H
or in this position I mean Fabiano now
knows that he is in shark-infested
waters this is going to be difficult to
maneuver if he wins this he deserves to
be well [ __ ] but there's a world
champion sitting across with him saying
I got you in my prep and I'm confident
let's go what do you wish a g5 is an
especially threes in his prep because
Bishop III is that is the secondary move
there and like all a Bishop g5 that's
the principal computer move but you've
got to look at okay what did the guy
decides I'm not gonna go down that line
you're not gonna burn all your bridges
in Bishop g5 right you've got to have
your backup move ready right it should
be 3a 693 Magnus is Magnus to play well
here's my thought process Jennifer cuz
you asked a very salient question how
deep is the problem are we still in prep
once we see this move h5 and it DePalma
h5 just as Matt and Maryse has been
showing really he kind of sticks out
there like a sore thumb right I mean
we're gonna play Bishop e2 we're gonna
constantly pressure this pawn on h5 and
make it very difficult for black to
Castle kingside
so we understand that we're gonna have
Bishop e2 as a main move we're gonna
have Bishop g5 because it's the easiest
move to play if threatens a queen with a
tempo and we're gonna have the move
Bishop e3 which is a very easy move to
play because it threatens a pawn with
the tempo so then we can easily see that
Magnus has got this position on the
board for sure and he's gonna say guys
I'm not satisfied with this preparation
there's too much at stake
Bishop e2 rather me
let's analyze some more he's gonna say
okay I've got to deal with the pawn on
b7 should I be worried about it Murray
says don't worry about it just play
Bishop e7 invite captures rook e8 rook
takes b2 and you're living large thank
you says Magnus okay what's the next by
the way just to follow that Rhino
what's SD things about this okay Queen
takes b7
no no no castles your H pawn is always
hanging right deal it when ready you're
paying attention to it or not
now ridiculously I'm gonna just this is
just ridiculous
was it what says he's gonna say next and
what a human player will have to assess
yes Queen side castles right now like no
no how is anybody play like this I don't
care what unless you have looked at this
for hey laughing there is no way as a
human you're playing this kind of chest
and I'm correct I'm correct about the
Queens gambit declined sorry sorry magma
stochastic castle twice without any of
these worries exactly and I've got it up
here it's Bishop e7 Queen d7 castles
castles Queen side allowing Knight takes
h4 Wow that's yeah sure maybe that's
best whatever but to humanize and all of
us here we're looking at it going
there's no way Bobby's doing that I
don't care if it's the best move on the
board
there's no way Bobby's doing that
there's gonna be pot shattering and he's
came forever after that right okay so
we're looking at Bishop e7 and then
we're looking at g3 because yeah that
looks like I mean that's such a human
move you're not gonna really tap this
pawn and after g3 we could imagine
castles again same issues we really
don't want to capture that pawn I have
to deal with rook e8 and the other stuff
now this is where it gets interesting
right here I'm saying Bishop e2 Magnus
has had this on the board
yes okay and now Maurice is a me for and
then this is Matt now Magnus is a number
two do you know what about Bishop g2
because if you feel like you don't you
have Bishop d3 on me huh
Bishop d3 is annoying
but also there yeah because you want you
want to put the bishop on that other die
I just wanted to stop before
so because the e4 was looking really
nice you mean you're trying to just
bother you figure out a blockade of the
that square there's gonna be some
challenges because yeah another point is
f5 huh is coming really really fast and
also not sure are you stopping for I was
also worried about viciously three and
rook c8 that was actually my concern but
that looks like a reasonable concern as
well rook the Bishop d3 I like Marie
Snyder just going up far but if you do
that on my Castle queenside sorry oh
well now now five is my five minutes
okay we get to play Bishop back to f5
he's gave me two Tempe it is a different
yeah if we gonna buy e4 here I don't
know no I didn't think of the move
Bishop g2 I it wasn't on my radar at all
I thought I was so natural so Bishop e2
and and Magnus says okay team you know
you're preparing me for a loss I'm
really unhappy look I'm gonna lose a
pawn what do you what do you got me
playing and they say no no no take it
easy
after the move e5 e for you're gonna get
really good compensation the knight is
going to come to e5 and actually White
has issues to deal with and then they
spend an hour to looking at this and
Magnus's confidence soars to such an
extent that he says okay I'm ready to
play this line and I'm saying that I
suspect team Magnus has looked very very
deep into the position they have on the
board and that if preparation is going
deeper than what I have right so you're
worried waiting for I would be worried
very very big time breaks news your
thoughts
breaking news those please instead of
playing let's back up after Bishop all
three a six-night c3 we got this dynamic
plays suggest Bishop e7 in castles right
dynamic player
dynamic play means nothing if you just
lose a pawn and the game is over right
hey you just lost the pawn so we're not
in the Age of intuition as much anymore
the one you could be like tall and say
you want my B pawn go right ahead
these days guys actually take those
things and say prove it right right and
they have a computer sitting next to
them saying yeah I got the pawn you got
no play trust me or you have play but
you get to play for about you know five
or ten moves and then you have to give
the toys back yeah then it's our turn
right so that's the kind of thing you
deal with now so Bishop e7 is definitely
a move that is sacrificial that is
unclear that is that is a little bit
wild but looks like black has
compensation that said Magnus has played
Queen to c7 and the engines hate this
move I mean they just they just think
why would you do that you don't need to
be playing gigantic Queen moves
defending pawns in such a way and this
move is not something that comes up as
first move by the engine I'm not even
sure if alas second move in fact
actually you know it was second move it
was the second move guard the pawn so
he's gone rogue almost with this very
solid move and I maybe I'm maybe that's
too much to say going rogue because he
sort of just left what looks like the
more enterprising sidelines and played
this move and I'm going to tell you that
the engines like white a lot after this
set C so much is at point five right now
with this move Queen c7 is this the prep
Queen c7 if I'm I'm going to tell you if
I'm white I'm relieved to see him move
like Queen c7 versus the sharp Bishop e7
Queen c7 seems like it slows down the
pace just a bit it gives me it gives me
a little tempo to breathe this move what
do you think guys I mean this doesn't
look like a testing variation that white
will be worried about that this came on
the board and now they're just playing
chess well first of all I'm with you all
the way on that one Maurice aye-aye
Queen c7 wasn't even on my radar not
even that's my second or third move
Bishop e7 just over row
everything because I just saw Bishop e7
black gets a safe King and with this
pawn out on h4 and these ideas of efore
I just thought the compensation huge now
after I see the move Queen c7 I started
thinking well yeah lost tempo sure you
know you're playing defense I think that
Magnus had this as some kind of a backup
line where you know he doesn't burn
bridges
maybe Bishop e7 and castles was the kind
of bridge burning thing here we could I
can understand that the difference and
Magnus may of like the the positional
aspect of this you're losing a tempo but
if you ever get your knight you get your
Knight to d7 in conjunction with the
Queen on c7 controlling the c5 square
I would like black and the reason is
because the Queen on before looks so
silly right
like you put the Queen back on d1 and
then play Queen d2 and then play d4 and
a 4 and you get right back into the
first two games that Fabiano was white
where he got the Queen side breaks and
right now his queen on b4 is in a kind
of a no man's territory so do you reckon
that Magnus also analyzed this and he
analyzed it a little bit more deeply and
feels that blacks practical chances are
high even if the computer doesn't favor
the middle yeah I mean I think that that
he just had a dual purpose approach is
what I want to say and oftentimes you'll
feel that at the board do you want to
play enterprising what do you want to
play solid so you don't think you
prepared this 97 specifically for this
game you think this was I think he did
well then wouldn't you know what he
wanted oh yeah no of the times you get
to the board and you change your mind
not the board yeah and you have two good
options
aha gotcha yeah well that makes sense
cuz also Fabi has thought but maybe like
he would have played the Bishop e7 line
at Fabi thought for like 4050 minutes
yeah like that you think where it kind
of depended on how shocked Fabiano
right and sometimes you pick up from
your opponent you know in this kind of
animalistic way that I haven't really
surprised my opponent that much like
maybe he's been working on this position
as well okay that would in that case I'm
gonna I'm gonna choose the solid line
well as opposed to going all out some of
the grandmasters we've had on especially
the elite ones to remind everybody we
have Gary we've talked about preparation
and said that everybody's using
incredible engine so if you're just
picking the engines first choice there's
a good chance your opponent analyzed it
and that the trick is to find a choice
that the engine doesn't necessarily
favor but if you go deeper suddenly
acceleration starts to sway you sighs so
that's a lot of the preparation game if
you will yeah that's really the art of
using the chess engine and I see these
you know elite players and I again I
gotta just say this she really really
hasn't pressed in his use of the engine
and just knowing how to you know guide
it a little tweak it look at this look
at that look at that just as you're
saying look at the second and the third
best lines according to the engines and
then find something there especially
like as Maurice was showing if the
engine line requires white to a castle
in some positions between filed in order
to get like that you know whatever then
you can say well what if they don't then
they're actually worthwhile this could
be a really good line exact so there's
some psychology intertwined with you
know question you can intimidate your
opponent you know a move like castles
immediately takes our breath away would
say oh you know don't do this without
you know really really a great deal of
preparation because you just be walking
into a Czech meeting matter but through
the contrary in these lines it seems
like weights moves suggested by the
engine or rather natural aren't they the
ones that you're putting on the board
like Queen c7 Bishop e2 in g3 and
castles sure yeah but again with
I mean the the ink the the inclusive the
inclusion of h4 h5 makes whites life
uncomfortable on the show and that you
are still an idea an idea and again
these positions black is looking for his
King side chances Maurice keeps coming
back to the move f5 f5 starts to look
really good when my opponent has played
h4 it really increases the value of the
King side attack now Murray's going over
to back over to you Queen c7 apparently
the second best move on the board how is
fat be supposed to continue the game now
g3
where we're there one move though I'm
playing like a beginner but it's move I
thought about and wondered about was
what if I attack the Queen we wish it to
be six is this just random I'm just
throwing the Queen out there for four I
mean throw attack out there for an
attack sake well I am trying to clamp
down on that square right I'd rather
have my knight there obviously then have
my bishop there but even so it is a
question as to what you're gonna do with
the Queen in this position and
especially you have this planner
bringing your Knight to d7 right if you
put your Queen over here then you say
then you've taken away that Square and
maybe at some point I'll bring my knight
and switch with you and get my knight in
on these six right I switch with that
Bishop so Bishop e6 Queen CA g3 this is
another principled way to play first
grabbing that b6 point and the engine
actually saved Bishop b6 second best
move to g3 immediately but only by a
little bit only by a tiny bit I had
something like point two nine versus
point two seven that's 29-cent I pause
versus $0.27 upon's
so this position still continues with
Bishop to e7 Bishop e2 Knight f8 looking
to get here and now you can play a move
pre-empting the idea Knight a for seeing
this move Knight d7 is coming you're
ready to bring your Bishop out and then
replace it with a knight you do have to
watch out for things like Bishop to e4
attacking your rook bit strange now
we're definitely in computer land as we
look at positions like this there this
you try to get a positional
understanding a feel of flow
but it's move by move right now it's not
like you see deep strategy at work it's
does this work or not
is this a better setup than the other
one I'm not really sure because we're in
a non-standard position there's gonna be
about who I'll plays the other I think
the opening now is basically I can't
call it concluded as people their
players are still trying to develop
their pieces and get the king's castles
but I think the opening prep like the
deep prep the things that you would have
to worry about as far as far he's
concerned he's not gonna get made it in
this line he's not gonna get blown out
by some novelty he's just in a new
position he hasn't seen before so it's
time to just compete as a player and now
we're at that phase where you start
coming up with your own ideas hope the
other guy hasn't prepared against them
and it's just chess Wow Murray's first
of all we're seeing a very chaotic
unclear position in an extraordinarily
high stress game man talk about amping
it up at just the right time who is this
favoring this kind of stressful well you
know Gary Kasparov who we had on the
show the last couple rounds yes it out
that it was a moment in game 10 where
were the nerves were at the absolute
highest as the championship crown hangs
in the balance and a competition both
players played like almost perfect chess
in to defy all odds so there was also
this idea that this idea that nerves
we're gonna affect the top players sure
in my mind make them play better number
two in the world that's extraordinary
yeah I mean I think of time travel is
making fools of all of us the chaotic
physicians as well Maurice and again you
know working when you're working with
engines as these players do every single
day of their life grew up on these
things and so they get to get a feel for
what the engine might say or what makes
sense Oh
nowadays it does look like much makes
sense at all when you're looking at
engines you have to try to make the most
of it
ceci is giving in this position I'm
going to give you one of those types of
positions
ceci is giving Queen a four so I'm
actually I'm gonna pull this up on the
bigger bore so you can see it
ceci
Queen a4 check okay Bishop d7 and Queen
b3 as White's best variation yeah I see
you shaking very much like how and then
by the way Bishop e7 g3 and you say what
is what why did you just lose a great
tempo to put your queen on B 3 because
ceci was control of the e4 square nice
for this night that was the point is
that such a critical point such a major
point putting your knight on the square
where f5 is gonna happen and allow for
and all that there is no way probably
plays that way like no way
all right it's just there's some things
that a human may say oh yeah that makes
a lot of sense I'm you know what I
didn't see that move but now that I've
seen it the way I'm nan said you know
once you see the computer move your
brain cancer and off from it this is one
your brain will turn off to say I'm
sorry
Queen a4 check Queen b3 I ain't playing
that that's ridiculous that's this
that's a gist from another planet and
you'd have to play a lot of moves to
justify that to feel to feel good about
yourself playing Queen a for Queen b3 so
you can work with computers up to a
point at some point your human side
takes over you say oh that's you know so
queen 8th work maybe for you ok by it
g3 Bishop b2 very very likely even that
idea of Murray's eye I saw a lot of
merit in that whole idea of redirecting
the night to b6 so something like g3
Bishop e2 night a4 I can see that we're
on the board right stock fish actually
likes it yeah yeah actually put it on
the board is like yeah that's
doesn't like it warm up to it it'll warm
up to it as soon as we see these are
logical moves these opposing we know you
can play this is human this is luck this
has been tried before we saw Fabia
tonight on b6 it has happened so you put
a 9 on b6 it's not the same as you got
in the previous game because now the
rook has a bit more flexibility than it
did now you will sit there and you guys
play g3 you're gonna play play Bishop e7
and 9 f8 and 97 that's what's gonna
happen once the rook moves away so
that's that's I can imagine the right
way you know like okay we're back into
some of those waters of a games 10 and
games 8 where you know remember fabbi
had a queen site lock down which was
much to his benefit and it was only
later when when things got really crazy
on the Kings side though that that man
is brain right that was looking good for
Fabio what about playing the night the
other way with the e4 and 85 sorry which
so we have this position after Knight a4
okay 48 and then after what were you
saying bishop I was you know me I like
to protect my pawn here's my g3 right
yeah yeah and then you were playing they
hear me or I was thinking at you for
before yeah here I'm not sure about the
knight f8 maneuvers I want to play
Knight e5 give myself the chance of it
attacking or defending with I do 7 I'm a
hundred percent with you on this I see
that the knight on e5 by the way is
played in like Game six and Game eight
with the pawn on e4 is definitely a way
to play I mean this is a very logical
flow for both players I'm still having a
lot of problems with my queen on before
I
doesn't feel like the Queen really
belongs and if Queen a for checking with
debate by the way okay well I like Queen
a4 check if I can get the guy to move
his king I mean you know okay I agree
with you it may not be that bad you'll
play Knight Knight e5 and g6 and your
castle by hey yeah okay but this is a
fascinating game we go back game can oh
yeah wait don't go now go forward 94 94
there's a b7 9b 648 yeah what is the
plan although it looks at this
coordinator for a moment no now I'm
looking at it it could be a problem
of rooks c1 I'm going all the way in
there's something I don't like about it
though and that is when I play c5 takes
I'm not worried about that what I'm
worried about is if I see 5n you take
and I play Bishop takes not my bishop is
paying me and that I am concerned about
but exactly but out I'll fix that engine
really doesn't like what I'm doing so I
I suspect is the problem for now and
maybe I miss times playing this way just
drop the plan the reason why I opened up
the game and I'm not developed at all so
I'm I'm afraid there's gonna be other
problems they're gonna pop up because it
takes before what about Ezra
oh yeah right well no I mean maybe it's
a very good exchange sacrifice yeah
Bishop III never works cuz of it should
be for Jack right so you're a double pin
working right now cross pin yeah not a
true cross pin but a nice double pin
happening in this position so since the
crossover dribble I mean Maurice is
right though Queens he's having kind of
induces ye to think about executing
right looks you want at the right moment
no not ver C 1 C 5 is 125 yet I want to
go back a move where go back all the way
before I play it C 5 right here now it's
my move yeah yeah
so if I play Bishop b2 here did you have
done c5 without Knight b6 okay sorry
so first of all seriously if you go
Bishop eat - no I want to see one of you
okay so rook okay sorry
okay so you want to play rook c1 yes and
after rook c1 I'll gosh I really want to
take this part no you doing man
every five I'm exactly as soon as you do
it or something you're trying something
beside see five years slow down but
should be to then see five every fiber
of my being wants to well once I play
there should be two night take stage for
your running an IG to Jack Bishop e2 you
really want me to take this ball anyway
it's not my and I think she to
definitely is scary because that I'm
taking off that dark suit alright could
I I'm gonna just give my you guys can
help me yeah no one thought I have his
rook takes on h4
followed by c5 in your Bishop and and
breaking through Bravo you're surrounded
by hyenas we're not here to Britt to
help you okay c5 okay so it's an
exchange you got some ideas should be
seven stuff again it's not always
annoying what okay so hold on what do
you want Jen you want to take on c5 and
that Bishop e7 e seven and this pin is
lights out or work takes me five bishop
ball I don't know I might have something
better should be same yeah Bishop takes
before check busy I'm convinced that
this is not good okay okay now let's go
back to my my main move I just
- look at that Sacrament right now what
happens on King f1 King f1 now where
pawn grubbers over here yeah
so we're thinking to grab some pawns
really yeah trying to grab more than
upon their yeah real now now both your
bishops are hanging you saying I sent
minors right okay I see Sakura h4 and
then have both bishops let's just like
you backed up sure this should be should
be four now that I supposed to place c5
or sac if I could see five I played with
myself this position can can use the
heat up guys we're gonna take a quick
break so we can have Darius borrow me
when Gary gets into position is gonna
get even more great yeah once Gary gets
in to refute all about well thank you
very much for joining us for the first
hour but it's gonna get even better as
this position critical to the World
Championship heats up we have Gary
Kasparov on the other side of the break
all right
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
health care in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation ascension is made up of
physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
healthcare innovators nationwide
ascensions faith-based heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
two billion dollars in care for people
living in poverty and for programs to
help them whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Chess Championship coverage where
Fabiano carolina st. Louis's own is
deadlocked with the reigning king Magnus
Carlsen and we are in the final
classical game of the match perhaps the
final game either man wins this game
they take the crown instantly it's
instant death but in victory at stake
and we've got a couple moves up from
when we had the break in this super
dynamic position yes take us through it
or Maurice was ready to actually all
right well we'll jump over because
controversy is definitely broken out on
the set Maurice you you you've lost your
drop your jaw you got it I'm picking my
Java you see Mike yes sir is a worry too
late picking my jaw up off the floor
that's what I was doing
f3 first of all g3 was played solid
Bishop e7 instantly f3 on the board by
Fabiano when you see it you say okay
we're gonna have a reat we're gonna try
to justify this move weakening this side
of the board it was already getting a
little bit porous over there now playing
this move f3 remember we all learned
develop your pieces get castled
make sure you have a safe place for your
king this King we weren't too thrilled
by putting it on the Queen side even
more so with this b5 opportunity at any
moment to be played we thought we'd have
safety on the King side but guess what
f3 says no I'm not even interested in
long-term safety for my king I'm playing
now for squares controlling this g4
square controlling more importantly the
e4 square as well at some point he can
also flick in g4 if you Castle yourself
this is super sharp stuff and I can tell
you I I'll bet mmm I'm not gonna give
away the house exactly but Elham Arabi
at least three of the rooms that dude
did not look at f3 anybody on the
of magnus carlsen looked at the move f3
and said principled way to proceed in
this position they looked at normal
developing bishop moves for sure maybe
something to land on b6 but that's got
to be here six seven eighth tried the
guy wants to play f3 he can go right
ahead
f3 talked about sharpening the battle
intensely I'm terrified for something
landing on that 4 eventually this pawn
especially landing on therefore this
bishop can move and you could get it
going this seems like a major decision
it is a major decision certainly as Sam
Shanklin says in his book pawns don't go
backwards
alright you put it there now what is
going on in this crazy position well
this is the exact kind of move that I
felt Fabiano was going to have to take
in this game it's a double-edged really
really risky move with a grounded in
positional fundamentals if we take the
move back for a moment before we play
the move f3
we had already been discussing pawn
sacrifice ideas of 'if I've be four
followed by Knight on g6 to e5 when
suddenly black is getting his whole army
coordinated especially this Knight on g6
it really stands off sites and this move
f3 just stops black's idea of a v e4 and
knight on g6 to e5 I'm going to invite
the greatest of all time mr. Gary
Kasparov to join us Jennifer to discuss
this move f2 f3 and whether he likes it
or not welcome back to the show the one
and only Gary khafre's yes thank you
very much actually my congratulations to
you and do all the chess fans because
this is a real game yes it is Gary yes
expectations of many that the game would
be an easy draw it's a fight absolutely
and again some of our predictions
materialized magan's followed the same
line and he just tried to make an
improvement and again Fabi is there food
like a sharp line but yeah I heard you
talking about a free and I tell me
because I just I
I didn't understand why Fabiana didn't
play Bishop g5 forcing f6 right yeah
it's it's it's amazing that you know
it's instead of forcing f6 which is it's
a weakness I mean it is no matter what
you say it's f6 is a weakness it creates
a potential weakness on e6 obviously one
day one can go in at five but still was
pollen pollen of six limits blacks
ability to to to create threats it
transmission from me from me seven so
instead of Bishop III I think Bishop g5
have seeds because he was almost natural
well Gary I have to say the engines give
Queen b8 as not as the more salient move
not the move Jesus yes the move f6 yes
yeah okay fine what's your next move
I pledge you three let's say right no I
make any one Bishop e2 I mean whatever
if I make any move so what's your next
move
it's a a six a six was the main line
with nine c3 and then Bishop to e7 was
given by the way night FA one ablai by
Magnus they pony 7 and play probably c5
I think why does a very comfortable game
I accept dairy I know exactly what
you're saying and we saw this position
by ceci and ceci throughout this move
rook c8 and basically said you know you
got into c5 you you traded bishops you
compromise blacks King but somehow the
computer is happy with black it was
crazy
talking about two humans great human to
read like chess so I'm just all I'm
saying is you know it was from it would
be far more natural a bishop g5 because
look win b8 is a machine move correct
this okay I'm at was played very quickly
so I assume he was prepared for Bishop
g5 and probably kuranes decision play
Bishop e3 was to actually take madness
away from from his preparation main
preparation that's my only guess because
not to spend you know no time so few
seconds by by making the first 10 or so
moves absolutely Gary your take on f2
ev3 your first knee-jerk response I mean
we've got a game we've got a great game
and shaping up
but f2 f3 do you like the move in
general no because it creates too many
potential witnesses okay Morris just
mentioned that you know the whole idea
of actual holding black on g6 Black
Knight on g6 they can fail because the
moment black pawn shows up on f4 wide
position collapses but as you pointed
out minute ago that there was another
way to do to activate the night to play
E for 95 so we'd say it's like you know
it's it's it's a train it's a very tough
train either you stop you for 95 or you
create a weakness which could
potentially exposed but trying to keep
Black Knight you know out of the game is
important though this Knight can go on
afraid on d7 now was Magnus's reaction
to the move f3 I don't know maybe I
would have would be 6 maybe I don't like
shinji Queens I don't know but but every
I mean I still want to play Bishop e2
and just potentially attack Poland h5
it's oh yeah just yeah but I agree with
you that you know if 4 is the stretch
because Knight goes only 5 and from e5
we can go to have free and this room
even if that's the movement as expected
could be a better choice after night it
looks like Magnus is still playing
extremely quickly do you think this is
just his clear plan or he's still in his
actual preparation no I don't need this
preparation but it's those move a very
natural for Magnus is is just it's a no
brainer so he always looks for four most
effective ways to improve his his
position and he looks at every piece
that he doesn't like and just finds
immediately the way to improve you to
bring it to a more productive Square and
night-night d6f 87 is so natural and
then I've got c5 and it kills Y its main
idea to play c5 I personally I think
black is absolutely fine now I would
prefer black position if you ask me so
because I see I see no no no real
content play for white so what's I don't
know what I can do yeah concretely
speaking the Queen on b4 if it doesn't
make if you don't get to play c4 c5 or
quickly as you had demonstrated in one
line a moment ago it feels to me like
the Queen on b4 just ends up being
isolated and not in the game Gary just
to just to take fabiana's position for a
second I'll play the move Knight e4 I
tried to make I'll try to justify
putting the pawn on f3 for a moment is
his first choice by the wave 94
recommended and I'm the only English up
to d3 after Knight d7
yeah I'm assuming Knight d7 right yeah
and I was gonna go Bishop d3 I'm trying
to make
maybe maybe g6 now first g6 preparing to
to take on e4 and then not o c5 so
that's the so after Bishop before what
will you take with Bishop or form well
here actually my biggest problem is
actually making a move and determining
what I want to do with my King 94 on the
board by 94 on the board your King
should go long I mean that's that's
probably well then I've got a the only
chance to create so real tension because
going short is just you know you don't
have any come to play okay so go long
I'll take your advice Gary yeah so
interesting by the way just going back
just just for a moment is I don't know
instead of f3 so don't you think that I
mean Queen b6
totally useless the Queen b6 there was a
key alternative yeah I just exchanged it
Queen I understand that you know you
don't really change coincidence the last
game but still and we're not talking
about the last game we're talking about
you know the objective quality of the
moves exactly well you put me on the
spot there Gary I I'm not sure if I like
efore Knight e5 when I don't have a
queen the Queen's yes yeah once you've
traded the Queen's I'm not a big
believer in the attack anymore maybe I
would try the same strategy as Magnus
did in the game bring the Knight to d7
yeah we think probably it's better for
white because you know then then you
don't have this my king can be on d2 I
played before just to beat a five with a
three Bishop count only three and I
think what and then I can play probably
a free and 94 I can move the same stuff
but without please yes actually because
that's why one of why's problem is a
king yes
so what so exchanging Queens we solve
the problem well I like the move Queen
b6 for all kinds of points of view first
of all I'm not a big fan of the Queen on
b4 to begin with I just think it's it's
in the way of b4 and it's not doing
anything useful secondly I really like
the idea of what you've just suggested
trade the Queens and solve the problem
with the White King White's the King can
stand e2 if ya know are of the board if
the Queen's are off the board all right
let's just see what we've got
do we have 97 Murray's have not yet but
I will interject by the way yes please
first of all Gary your Queen b6 ancients
think agree with you slight edge for
white definitely slight edge for white
however the engines also like Poppy's
planet they think 94 in this position
and keeping Queens on especially 97
Bishop d3 is still fine for white now
you suggested to move g6 Gary in this
position and the engines now giving the
move rook c1 saying we're going straight
ahead with our plan if you take money
for take back with a pawn on e4 and
that kind of Kings Indian Sun formations
I shouldn't point out the move Bishop g6
is also playable with the threat of at
five and the engines don't worry about
this threat as fast as it might be
coming and feel that White will be able
to manage that position as well yeah but
wait more is better since this you know
rooks e1 Bishop takes e4 f2 X t4 and
then I just you know bring my kingdom
okay I can probably do a castle short
castle of course or bring my King Khan
g7 18 g7 even I don't know and then it
seems to me that you know our block you
know I mean I can hardly imagine you
you're making any any progress on the on
the Queen side though you have said the
open-air file maybe that's that will
give you some chances so with a bit of a
Queen d2 maybe before they've been toss
it in give me some moves BC 3 what's the
good move for black g6 is not really
clear by the end Roxy one and you guys
were looking at Bishop b4 mmm-hmm and
was it and we were with the pawn correct
we've dropping a knight maybe maybe I
should play b6 or even or even you know
what maybe I can play 95 well I play
Knight c5 actually I don't want it
either b6 or not C but I don't want to
take only for two earlier why why should
i do over and file so what night c5
attacking the bishop you mean before
Bishop takes e4 yeah yeah i watch them
live without visual tasting for you
immediately
yes it's illegal
[Laughter]
okay so 95 here d c5
flower check check we shall be settled
your back and then queens somewhere like
a week ago
afraid of a foreign yeah I maybe six
floors but then you know I don't know I
can maybe even two
one castle now your king is still you
know on eval this would be it's a sharp
gauge okay castle castle be for just for
fun before before guys have to react
after before so you can play a five and
start you know playing it that's crazy
stuff before at five oh boy talk about
retching the tension of the man 53 was
played by the way you're closing in on
our position now yeah it's not about you
know setting up a bed but what do you
think the chances that the match will be
over today who which means one one
player wins 50/50 I was I would say with
more than 50/50 because of the position
and it seems that again is this the
plants are engaged so there's a little
bit fight okay so again I think it's a
very good chance that is that's the
actually the pressure could play play at
recon one prayer of another or both
apparently the markets this morning said
two to one that it was gonna be a draw
but of course they didn't know that we
were in half this position on the board
exactly discussed you know it's just the
it's when Magnus play in most of the
games Magnus played was black you know
they had very sharp positions and
especially in the last two games 8 and
10 and and providing Magnus you know was
about to choose the same line I mean the
fight was almost guaranteed so that's
why I think two-to-one was was a wrong
bet
yeah Gary in in decisive games like this
one you've been in multiple matches
having to deal with critical games where
I think there was a quote I heard they
called a squeaky bone work squeaky
squeaky Bob well you start feeling
nervous
this is like the money game what what
are your thoughts going into a game like
this one how do you prepare for the
greatest game of your life the way Bobby
had to go mycorrhiza Morris I have to
tell you that I never was in the same
situation because all the sides of games
I played there were in the match that
that was the last game of the match
period right so that's why either had to
win to retain the title or to draw to
retain the title or just you know just
it was just a last game so whatever you
whatever whatever you your plan was for
the game you know that's it that's that
was it so you couldn't actually think oh
if I make a draw it goes to tiebreak
right so that's that creates a very even
worse yet no it wasn't kind of oh he's
saying it's an all-or-nothing game time
set for you it was for you or not this
is not all nothing because the drawer
imagines exactly that's that's why both
players they have in mind that they you
know that's taking too much risk might
be premature because they're still you
know it's still time right they're
wiping Magnus is it their favorite but
still it's at the end of the day it's I
mean if if Robbie has to make a choice
between a no suicidal
a risky option or a quiet one I think he
would go for a latter because again it
is no need for him to take the same risk
as if they play the old-fashioned match
world the world champion retains titles
retain his title in case of a time right
so still the question is still there for
you what how did you get ready
emotionally psychologically for that
kind of all-or-nothing battle look it's
there's there's no universal advice it's
you know it's it's up to you actually to
make yourself ready and you know that's
that's that's what makes the difference
between the very good players and the
world champions and I'm still asking you
how did you do it forget about the rest
of us
how did you do it comfortable because I
you know it's I I've been comfortable in
the wrong Ward but I felt that it oh it
was you know it was the moment where I
could in a test my my character in our
and it's all I did before so it's for me
it was great opportunity to show to show
so my best abilities so that's the way I
treated the game yeah I remember reading
a book from you Gary where you talked
about Seville and preparing for game 24
a must-win game and you play cards the
night before because at that point you
already played Anatoly Karpov so many
times you would prepared for him there
was nothing you could do in the next 12
hours that was going to change anything
might as well play some cards and yes
it's it's the end of the day what I know
about these final games it's still the
mistakes are being made and you have to
make sure you don't make the awesome so
and that's why even in this game so the
mistakes will be made
and let's see though who who blinks last
exactly
now again referring right back to the
position Gary Bishop d3 a moment ago
you'd almost almost crept in a slight
bias for a black musician considering
considering I'm just again I played I
played this kind of positions in
Sicilian mainly from the black side so
that's why you can't go wrong you can
hardly blame me for my prejudice because
you know I used to look at this from day
from from the opposite side so from from
the back side right absolutely
it's this plaintiff of play there and
it's I I don't know actually matters has
to make some tough choices now because
either he takes only 4 or he goes from
95 to this structure but he has to make
a very important strategic choice now
yeah is its position is highly unusual
so because it looks like white position
is very it's almost exposed so there's
the pawns moved and a lot of weaknesses
but still why it has something draw
you know more struggles in the center a
little bit more space and black has to
think about you know creating
counterplay Plus in gone you wanna you
know I mean it does have to you to go
one way or another it could go to it's
two to two shorts Castle it could go the
long castle you could stay only to you
I'm curious about is easy there's no it
does it's not an immediate threat so
black has to make some tough choices now
and I'm curious what will the mothership
could we try could we try a couple of
moves and just tell me if I'm crazy
because to me if I'm playing this with
white the thing I'm most concerned about
is that F pawns just charging down the
board but apparently it's possible to
fight against this move but what if you
play a secure move like Bishop to g6
with the idea of playing for f5 and
maybe f4 or maybe even the sacrifice f5
with E for sacking to put the knight on
e5 it's it looks it looks crazy but it
looks like the kind of fun you could
have with the black pieces yeah I lost
the connection for a moment yeah yeah so
I was I was saying Gary yeah I was I was
saying buddy connections card so it's
the that it's it's tough for matters
because they're all safe choices each
choice you know carries certain
positional risk right and because you
know he put a sign on d7 and it's a
choice either goes 95 or intentionally
for our egos Bishop d6 hoping for a 5
one day and that's what Gary that's
where that's where when we lost you I
wanted to go down that line the move
Bishop to g6 what do you feel about this
amping up the pressure on that side and
preparing at five what do you think
about this planet we take a look at a
couple of moves yeah but five okay if
five white night goes on g5 so then then
you probably go 95 years I was I was
even looking for to somehow play the
movie for I'm not sure if in combination
with with a capture on g5 first so
Bishop teasing sounds you know like it's
very decent option because it's they
again now White has to make to make next
move and I tried castles just putting
something on the board so you guys could
throw the patties at one another long
Castle b5 won't gasp yes he's trying
short castles short castle Bishop g6
short castle and if in case of an f5
Knight g5 maybe you want to rename a
castle first maybe Castle black also do
that also should do short castle right
and now white needs a move yeah cuz that
five is definitely on the menu there
five minutes and and and then I see five
yes yeah okay Queen d2 all right now the
fun starts we're already in the fire
let's play at five let's see what
happens yeah kill that night we our
[ __ ] is bad anyway we don't need it you
take on g5 yeah now do we play E for and
95 is that just random for you for loop
you know you played you for I played
Bishop e2 I don't have to take mm g6
looks a bit 95 not bad by the way you
could take on f3 point 95 and get that
with tempo goes on at 4 or CC and my
bishop goes on therefore and still your
bishop on g6 is a bit old this until the
bishop looks strange
yeah yeah man Terry this is like because
Ruby 894 it's just yeah
but Gary for me if I'm Fabiano I'm super
super happy because I've got to say I
feel like I want to avoid the tiebreaker
I really do I've got a position that's
double excellent
nablus bled castle magnus played sorry
innocent he cancelled immediately yeah
he's still probably wants to keep both
options it castles short
pardon me let me correct myself it looks
like I don't see that yet but it looks
like
I don't have castles on my board but
Gary does so I believe I believe in
Karen I trusted you speaking of which
Bobby gave us all a little bit of a
scare
Gary earlier in the game when we
wondered if there was any chance he was
gonna go for a repetition early in the
game did you have any doubts no I have
no doubts about it so does this did it's
yeah if this choice Bible 13 I think you
know that he could go for that but to do
it at you know move 10 yeah it would be
basically moral capitulation it's not
just you know considering the fact that
Magnus is a favorite in in in in rapid
bye-bye-bye but blowing up his chances
was white without even trying
that'll be morally devastating
absolutely I agree it's a right choice
and I had no doubt that he would
consider actually I thought he would
definitely Bishop g5 so that's why yeah
I didn't understand why he's been so
much time that's it that's a very
natural move but again you should be
three and now we have something else
so Gary I could ask you a question for a
second and it has to do with preparation
and I just want to bring you back to
this moment in time when h4 h5 so h5 was
to quote the theoretical novelty from
this position onwards how many moves of
preparation do you think Magnus move is
very surprising so we're double what I I
have the move rook h2 after castles on
the board man I'm just checking
that's se I'm also getting updated rook
h2 as the as the next move and then it
has been confirmed it is that rook h2
that's its intentions very clear now you
want to play long castle and to meet b5
who's Lucy - yeah that's very clear but
but Wow with
all this energy coming on the other side
rook h2 what a move let's look you know
if he glanced along castle yeah see
that's natural you know he wants to make
sure that b5 will be will be met by
rusev we got the idea though we get the
idea but he's committed now he was safe
for it we're relatively safe on g1 but
he's decided to go all in with the King
on seat on c1 that seems super sharp as
the decision okay you know it's remember
we talked many times about it you know
you keep saying he doesn't care about
being safe this game decides whether
you'll be wall jumper or not and if he
if he believes that you know they is
fighting in a overwhelming odds and in
Rabbid he doesn't care about safety
exactly the game and he wants you know
to use every chance he has in this game
but is this risky now is this risky
remember you talked about it being an
ally yes more is game of chess as Queen
before now it's a risky game but that's
that's a world championship match and
it's as you have been saying all three
you know for us dinner an hour and a
half it's you know it's it might be
mostly poor getting his life absolutely
he's willing to take chances
that's a baller move that's a baller
move I'm sorry rook h2 to say yes I'm
gonna go for it I'm gonna Castle
queenside I'm gonna go into the teeth of
the attack potentially my only quietly
question is now this is this is what
happens if Magnus tastes hov fool takes
I need for ya I'm in this case tempted
to take with the pawn Gary not that
seeks Knight f6 okay I thought you were
gonna go for c5 but you're actually
heading for g4 now that my rook is
committed itself anyway and night yes
rook to c2 I like that move down g4
Bishop do you want yes
no no that's the so that's the look then
lukkage toons
surprise I don't know it's the can man
I'll probably be five is a little bit
too much it reminds me this rook HT rook
C to have certain French defense shifts
where you've already played F for what
about what about now yeah another
question for me Gary is what about the
immediate Knight c5 with the rook on h2
because then potentially four might be
you know who's King whatever we can
probably try to use this I don't know c5
d c5 take on this really for yes exactly
exactly
even yeah II for or as you just said
take take efore with I ideas of Queen
takes g3 check here's another dangerous
idea by the way
what's this is dangerous let's say back
that night up in this position dish of
g6 Bishop g6 yeah and this is to fight
against castles because if you castle
now we can't continue queenside castle
f5 right and now your Knight g5 is met
by trade trade and when I play E for now
you're not so happy about you know that
rook on h2 because you're gonna play
you're playing Bishop e2 before yeah at
Bishop e2 if you play it now your work
on h2 looks ridiculous also he could
trade on f3 twice and then play 95
continue this way this is more
positionally founded by the way yeah 95
and now you gotta play Bishop e2 and now
you're open H do really looks random and
when rook c8 shows up on the board all
of a sudden it's only one person who's
doing anything in math yeah no this one
is scary
that's not and well positionally found a
nothing strange for black there just a
normal straight play trying to exploit
this brooke age to move well just
playing normal chess ensuring the root
page to move is flawed and this looks
dangerous to me just dropping back to
play for f5 how about g4
well okay well I'm committed to castling
long and then that's in the case for
some time Maurice so I'm not worried
about gee for once I've basically I
burned my bridges I'm gonna castlelong
you didn't just burn the bridges you got
the G for rookies doing G for as your
moves dude I gotta stop at five you you
you you you panicked me yeah you showed
me a five and I said scared scared me
after 95 before now you think was a
bishop yes after 95 you have to K was a
bishop I have to yes yes Gary you're
right I have to take and then you go
back on c3 maybe who's queen or d2 and
the lone castle and you are fine I am
dreaming about putting my king into
safety you're right Maurice is trying
something different it's a very it's a
very kiss Peruvian move in fact with
Britt of g6g four it's a position to
move because you know if f5 is a stretch
so you have to you know you have to
protect your knight yo it basically said
saving your position in the center
because if you if you you know if you
allow a5 that everything collapses so
that's why g4 probably is the only move
well Gary but I'm gonna play a move that
I've seen you play millions of times
before
okay maybe not millions but the kind of
thing when I was studying your books the
test of time and all the great books you
wrote that could drop on this board is
the move b5 yes I said you know yeah
love that move and already giving black
a serious advantage because white is
being torn apart
and the seams as the structure is just
collapsing and where do you put your
king now that b5 is on the board I don't
know I you know again ten minutes ago
let me remind you I told you that I like
by its we're gonna play the tape
because again a freeze is it's it's it's
again it's a it's a big choice and Ruth
gates
- it just keeps amping up he's trying to
prove that he can play slowly in a
position that that has palm breaks from
life that bad now it's again obviously
if Y can actually go along castle and
then c2 then white has a great great
position the problem is in our own chest
you're always missing one tempo to be
happy
right well Gary wanted to trade Queens
earlier is why it is Lowry well yes but
I see this move Bishop g6 as being a
fundamental question in the position why
should I give up my two bishops for the
knight on e4 why don't I play for the f5
II for as gary said the moment white
played f3 white was always fearing an f5
f4 and in this position it's the biggest
challenge and if I have to play g4 well
then this b5 and you know fire on board
right Gary every across every sector the
center of the Kings side the Queen side
we have enormous clash and black looks
more sound solid his King a safe or
after all
King safety very important in the
opening well apparently in the nor we'd
TV studio when he when Magnus played b5
in game 10 they were also just like
blown away they thought that this was
like an incredible move and that he was
gonna win
really yeah whereas I thought the wing
gambit before by fabbi was an incredibly
that blew me away by the way I'd like to
add just so that everybody can really be
scared and worried for five years the
move rook c2 I tried to defend the
position I said wait a minute my work is
gonna get caught on the H file and I can
get it over to c2 is what I want to do
anyway and I get to proceed with my plan
if only I could just castle the problem
is f5 9 g5 and suddenly Knights c5 and
white is getting roasted
this position as the bishop is hanging
the rook is now exposed on the c2 square
because anything like Bishop to e2 just
runs it to f4 sorry you're gonna die now
oops and and if you play after 95 Bishop
takes e5 d takes e5 again you have
threats you have to deal with the bishop
is hanging efore is coming the Queen the
Queen is her problem on this square you
don't have time as Eve or will blast
open to the g3 point I mean you're in
deep trouble in that line but Magnus did
not play Bishop g6 instead he's played
rook a to c8 whoa and I feel like
Bobby's fans got to feel like he dodged
a bullet
even if this move is good that Bishop g6
will look so principled but rook rook a
c8 is on the board
Wow we have look on f8 or rook on a 8 I
currently have rook a to C okay long
castle yeah that's the question right
now if white gets the time to walk
nestled put his king into safety on b1
well for sure Magnus had prepared rook
c8 glum castles b5 rook CCU okay Oh at
least at least tie my king is an insect
by king is safe yeah exactly it's not
not that I'm very happy but it's much
better than what we saw today
nobody's doubting you their engines
still giving though this this idea a
stamp of approval instead of instead of
playing b5 playing Bishop g6 and rear up
now for this move f5 with tactics bishop
g6 again at least your king is over
there but are you really safe because f5
is coming not clear is not clear where
White's
play is by the way it should be pointed
out in this line y as you could take
well how'd you get your kingdoms move
one after Bishop g6 I like King b1
gotcha okay I didn't go rook c2 is not
not the same effect because I could play
room C - exactly
f5 Nagi 595 I can take on c5 because my
kingdom I don't see one who she does no
good to blacks because II four is no
longer a deadly threat since Queen takes
D Street just you know it's not a check
but can I take on g5 and then play
anymore
I think Bishop c5 so how do you play
Bishop g5 check or or let's say I just
take area where Queen takes e5 then they
can we take c5 Queen takes t5 Bishop
takes g5 hd5
rook c5 yeah and for f4 you really
you're really trying to kill my mission
aren't you
maybe I get played before I see five
full look it's it's all of a sudden it's
black shouldn't be walking it why
shouldn't be black shouldn't be allowing
this position maybe instead of I was
saying after 95 just take right away and
then play 44 Bishop takes d5 after 95
Bishop takes d5 Bishop takes d5 84 yeah
that makes more sense
oh yes yes but it's this it's yes it's
the mm-hmm therefore is this red yes
hopefully
suddenly a four becomes an idea then I
goes to e5 from black point of view
there's still some some stuff being
thrown out white in that position
yeah I might be able to defend but he's
definitely stuff being thrown at it
Wow okay me and again
magnets with a big time edge so what is
the time Magnus has an extra half-hour
so which could be very relevant in this
situation right we don't know absolutely
but Jennifer just give us an ID like 40
minutes to an hour in can approximate
and they got to get to move 40 before
this right right and we remove 21 Wow
okay
so significant edge super sharp position
man Gary this this game 12 is living up
to everything we could have possibly
hoped for but you're shaking your head
Gary there's something in your face not
yet because you hope for one result it's
it's a great it's a great game but it's
very dangerous for white and and I get
go let's go back and every is just just
you know was a very risky move because
it we can't watch position right I want
to create witnesses Janice yes yeah as
you can see so many problems that that
was it has been experiencing and all the
lines that we have we've analyzed
they're connected to the fact that every
is if this move create weakness on g3
it's wicked in the white position in the
center and you know some it hasn't you
know reached its goal of limiting black
counterplay who the contour it created
some more potential targets that move
rook age to Gary that to me that seems
like more even more if you're gonna play
f3 you and all in with rook age - you're
saying I will one day Castle queenside
and be okay and it looks like that one
day is probably to be very difficult
movie to make a ride just trying just
you just to play the game must be to
Pizitz to positional so he just you know
he looks you know it's again in ideal
world you know hopes to castle and to
concede you but there's no ideal world
you look a little bit worried are you on
Team Bobby no no I'm just you know I'm
I'm looking at a position I'm trying to
actually analyze it I had so look at the
screen and I don't know I'm as I said
you know i always prefer black you know
in this kind of bone structure and
relocates you don't bring any confidence
right in fact you prefer to be black if
you were playing this in a world
championship match
even if I played bliss geisha thank you
so very much for having joined us on
this the 12th and decisive game of the
match I'm assuming you're gonna be
around the whole of the day right yeah
absolutely and the game is a tie so we
meet again on the 28th Wow
that's something to look forward to we
would love to have you on the show if
you're available thank you so much as
always for joining us Gary okay bye-bye
thank you and bye bye
what a treat to have Gary Kasparov the
thirteenth world champion joining us to
talk about the position although for
Fabi fans certainly his prognosis and
his desire to play black hair not that
it was firing well but well not not that
it's not inspiring but it's concerning
well for sure and he was very consistent
too wasn't he from the very beginning he
was really like the foundation black has
and he wasn't a hundred percent sure but
once he saw the move f3 he just had old
boy black has these options this option
he could play for b5 he can do this and
this and this he really like Magnus why
did not have to Castle why did not delay
the move to World Championship dance we
have these two players we already had
Gary we will have the player who
actually defeated him to take away his
title coming up next Vladimir Kramnik
and chronic will have a thing or two to
say about the specialty called as well
but guys I got to say rook age to f3 was
one thing right f3
was loosey-goosey positionally minded
grabbing the e4 square their arguments
to say f3 was weakening but they're also
arguments to say it maintained the
position control and relaxed setup so
that he wasn't in any major danger white
but once you put the rock on h2 you're
you're basically like I said the ideal
world you're hoping please one day not
please actually you played okay so
you're saying I am definitely castling
queenside and I'm definitely gonna be
able to play rook c2 and you can't do
anything about it you don't know
- that's gonna be something that is
debated if he loses his game as to why
he played were caged sue and he did in
fact Castle queenside so that is on the
board now rotates to that controversial
move and he has now castled into the
teeth of it saying I am going all-in
this is you know there are certain
things that define a a player is going
to be the champion it defines you what
kind of risk are you willing to take
remember yeah sir before this I said to
you I like your argument about risk what
risks do you take to prove I'm the man
now I'm the top dog I'm the number one
player in the world I don't care if
you're gonna look like you're attacking
me it looks like you're trying to
steamroll whatever I wanted to take this
chance and go for it
so that I can become the champ this is
Fabiano's moment right here with his
move castles and he's just daring Magnus
will it pay off or will it fail
miserably only time is gonna tell on
this one but just an amazing moment as
he takes the bull by the horns by the
horns to say I want to become champion
and I'm willing to do whatever it takes
to do it I love it game 12 in moving up
the expectations but guess what it gets
even better as we have Vladimir Kramnik
on the other side of the break and I
can't wait to hear how his opinion
differs from Gary because he is not Gary
you kind of expected that he would say
give me black to me black and me black
just like in game 10 but remember when
we had on on Doyle and the story was a
little different so where will karmic
fall what's your prediction
I think he's gonna team up with Gary but
I do think this was the money move join
is on the other side of the break to
find out
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Louis chess club
to start a top-tier collegiate chess
team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best University at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University you may have heard about st.
Louis's world-class museums art history
science even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
those kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage we are in the
money game five and a half points for
our American challenger Fabiano Carolina
five and a half points for the reigning
champion Magnus Carlsen but the game
we'd be more thrilling yes as opposite
side pathos lots lots of for black to
play for and if white weathers a storm
could be positionally advantageous for
Bobby what's your take now after we have
done a couple more moves in just before
a break time it was very very relieved
to see this move castles long by Fabiano
we thought that the move rook on a eight
to c8 that lost the tempo kind of moved
just allowing white get his King into
play Bishop g6 this was by far the most
contentious and challenging move in the
position as black just brings his bishop
it to protect this quote where but more
importantly readies the blow f5 to chase
this Knight out of the center and then
follow it up with ideas like efore and
there's always a b5 so that was why fab
he played the move rook c2 protecting
his king stopping the move b5 because
there would be a capture and a tempo
against the Queen and then after the
move f5 on break Maurice Rhett's
and I were actually spending a lot of
time analyzing the move Knight g5 and
after a lot of craziness we came to some
scary positions for white no doubt there
was lots of sharing complications to
navigate and then instead of Knight g5
which for some reason we were thinking
it because also like it seemed like it
cuts off some bishop escape squares
after f4 right that I think that's one
reason why it doesn't look appealing of
course right now the bishop on g6 is
hanging right I think that's maybe
that's why mentally you know you look at
95
it doesn't block your bitch's pathway
okay we've got something concrete
Maurice I'm sorry but yes please more
critically your night sucks I'm sorry
sophisticated analysis the night you you
look at the night where does the night
want to go now I mean the night is
sitting on that square where what is its
intention I almost want to maneuver it
to age to page three so I can go to g5
what is what is the night why I guess
the planner I mean but basically the
point is Fabi didn't want those
variations where you got to play Bishop
g5 55 and e4 so he was maybe so now you
are covering me for sweat that is true
that is true but that said you know
you're talking about that line versus
your night you're having a bad square
and you're gonna have to figure out how
to improve this piece because it's on a
bad square right now that's why the wing
week 95 95 has been played to underscore
that you know you go from having a
centralized night on the e4 square with
the potential to move forward to square
like g5 you have a night on d7 that's
sitting there laying in wait all of a
sudden what do you get you get a pawn
move that forces the knight back to the
unusual f2 square with the with us
wondering what its prospects are what
are your next couple of moves with that
Knight right and our knight leaping to
the c5 square with ferocious ideas
suddenly in a position to capture on d3
threatened potentially f4 being
threatened we should also point out the
time situation is huge for Magnus right
now he's up over 30 minutes on the clock
as we speak and in response to this move
instead of taking on c5 and computers
were giving this as required in this
position
Fabi has played the move f4 on the board
right now and the engines are really and
seriously liking blacks position more
and more this night of to book will he
regret it and the time he spending on
the clock he's feeling the pressure to
heat as Magnus is looking to knock him
out in this game no tiebreak necessary
yeah well I'm kind of recoiling exactly
b5 is 93 I takes d3 but I really do want
to emphasize what Maurice
sighing about the move Knight f2 for
just a second the knight on e4 is on a
great circuit and the problem is and
I've seen it time and time again from
the great players vichy Gary Vladimir
Kramnik who's coming up by the way they
drive their opponents knights to these
impotent squares where the knight just
has no chance of jumping back into the
play this pawn on f5 essentially
dominates this knight on the episode and
then after 95 it's very clear that well
Black has all the play you just
mentioned it that yourself Jen maybe v
e5 with the idea of Knight takes D 3
this rook on c2 is going to like
protection you won't be able to capture
that pawn on d5 and black will just be
able to open up the position and on his
choosing
next problem and you mentioned this
Maurice long time ago when you saw the
move f3 you were always fearful of the
move f4 that it would just blow up the
King sight so you could imagine a
position with Knight takes D 3 on tap
followed by F 4 and bad things started
happening to White's position just like
that that's when suddenly f4 by the
options to look appealing I mean I can
even I feel like I'm looking at b5 e 4e
takes that forward with the bishop
coming to f6 it just feels like every
single line there's something happy for
some kind of happiness robot look look
at the pieces look at the the the
difference is in the position between
white pieces and blacks pieces now why
doesn't one solace as the rest of your
pieces look awful and the King's safety
with b5 coming with threats you're gonna
have to kill that night on c5 just to
deal with all the agony that you're
about to face this position just
everywhere you look you do have to
glance at it to look at the coordinated
action of blacks forces versus the
mismatch just like random placement it
looks like Queen on b4 not connected to
the knight on f2 the 911 not having a
real future Bishop on e3 kind of just
standing there the rooks are not
connected the
King would rather be on b1 and c1 I mean
there's so many minuses that you can't
count on just a bishop on g6 as the only
thing that's compensating back
recognition
this is tempo all day for black Robbie's
gonna have to put on his best defensive
hat and hope that Magnus plays quickly
and make some kind of error because this
is definitely a blacks favor
good defense has been the name of this
match but I mean you're absolutely right
it was Garry Kasparov who said you're
always behind a tempo but you're
especially behind a tempo when you
Castle queenside because amazing view on
King b1 and then if you combine that
with the rock age to see two more long
winded maneuver it's not that shocking
but not to mention just the whole nature
of playing white and the special kind of
line where you're moving your knight to
be five to a three and just making so
many knight moves it's not that
surprising that black has a development
edge in a lot of situations so it's not
your pure development I'd hear it's just
that can be one move but famous last
words just that move right yeah you need
a tempo and it's really really hard
Maurice it's really hard I am stunned I
am really starting as I'm as I'm going
through this watching the way Magnus
plays attacking positions it's as though
he said those not in his fingertips the
same way I mean it guys you give him a
chess problem he's gonna solve it
instantly but some of his attacking the
attacking type setups where you you go
you flow like a garry kasparov you just
you know rook rook g3 and it's in that
game where you just knock the guy out
you've seen it even when he played h5
played a little bit too quickly when he
was going on the attack and it didn't
work in that game in the English in this
one he's now played a move that I will
just tell you just paradoxical to play
is the move a5 like my queen is not
happy on the square before it was to
come back into the action we're talking
about the disc coordinated play involved
in in having this Queen sitting on this
point to bring the Queen back to guard
the rook in some kind of way that alone
is a tremendous benefit to bring the
Queen back and guard the bishop they're
just a couple of moves that you push
this Queen to a better Square by playing
this move
and it really is odd to see this move on
the board and that that's just for
starters this is optically to think
about it from a strategic standpoint but
you got to wonder why push the Queen
away and then when you start asking the
engines well what do you think about
this move and they're also saying no
this this helps white tremendously in
the situation I'm very confused by the
the giving the conceding of the b5 point
in this situation now you can't even
open the a file if you played b5 see Vav
you don't get to open the a file as well
just in case you want to get an attack
going down there all the streams were
streaming attack would happen this one
guys a5 that's just very strange to see
Magnus play this movement he's playing
rather quickly given that he has so much
time in his clock he hasn't really borne
down and gotten into all the details off
of the position it's almost as though
he's feeling fabi's time pressure we've
seen this happen before
maybe he's a little bit nervous too
playing very quickly automatic moves
that may not be ideal for this situation
Bobby's got to breathe a sigh of relief
I don't think he's breathing any side
really good given how he feels it must
must be a mile a minute but this move at
least seems to have a let go of that you
know the the hole he had on Fabi and has
given him a little bit of a chance Wow I
find the move very perplexing as well
Maurice for everything you've said I I
thought the Queen on b4 was misplaced to
begin with so you're just pushing
White's Queen to a superior square
whatever that superior square might be
so Queen d2 by the way was played also
because I just thought b5 was so
compelling to open up lines on the on
the Queen side a5 Queen d2 on the board
so a little bit perplexed by this move
the the one thing I think the move does
have going for it like imagine black is
thinking I'm just gonna shut down the
Queen side which is kind of contrary in
right I'm gonna play b7 b6 you're gonna
play King b1 and I'm gonna turn all the
attention all the gravitas of the
position towards the center so
me just play Bishop f6 I'm not going to
do anything particular gen so just like
no I'm not gonna close it down with a
farm just gonna I'm just gonna put my
pieces in the center my next move might
be B 7 B 6 so then all my pieces are in
the center and I'm saying you white will
have to justify your rook being on c2
which which would work maybe if you
could get in B 4 and C 5 you're real
gutsy - but if the center if the Queen
side get shut down after 85 and B 6 and
the Brooklyn C 2
it's gonna be a Lopez Miss place we
already have established the knight on
f2 is no great shakes right and for the
moment black just controls the center
and challenges white to come up with an
effective plan and it while it it's kind
of a risk free attack and it's kind of
confounding there's nothing wrong with
this I mean it's it's a challenge for y
to improve his position yeah I mean I'm
just trying to think also about the
possibilities what are some other good
things about a 5 because I alright
that's what I'm trying to think about
Magnus like I mean obviously you
understand that V buddy yeah so I feel
like maybe there's something in there
two of you must have play like c4 and
reroute his bishop feels like a five
might involve trying to play 44 and put
this guy maybe five anyway play like we
should be a then B 5 or a 4 well yeah I
can imagine a hit might be three so many
weird ideas where you can check 84 and
then you can't play b3 because a bishop
takes B free black is still better but
this way you there are some ways to be
worse and there's some ways to be worse
this way of being worse as far as white
concerned is definitely better than the
other way the other way the guy is
trying to rip your head off right right
you're just you're you point b5 and
saying ha look at your position how you
feel now this way is I got you and
squeeze you know it's almost what people
would suspect from Magnus the way he can
just control a position no
risk on his side in just control and
control and control I think a lot of
people I can imagine like Judith Hoag
are saying like why'd you just go kill
him like just go get him
this one is more sedate more controlled
let's look at the position still
objectively speaking white doesn't have
much to do before praying Bishop e2
efore after Queen D 22 right Queen d2
actually Bishop 6 was not played a5
Queen d2 and now the movie for shutting
it down shutting it down and now we're
expecting the move Bishop to e2 employed
and now we have this position black says
white you don't have anything to do with
your confirmation
there's no before there's no a 3 B 4
gonna happen either
there's no g4 there's there are no pawn
moves for you period
so I've shut down anything you can do
and now I'm going to slowly prepare the
idea of b5 which you probably can't stop
and then hope that that's good enough
like that's gonna make the position work
was this the best way to go I see a
night landing somewhere somewhere back
here bishop again trying to threaten
Bishop a4 scoring the rooks you can't
play v3 because if Bishop takes b3 so
how does Bobby play against this I mean
King b1 Bishop a4 now you can be three
let me first of all you need to play g6
because I'm gonna tell you if you play
Bishop a4 I'm sacking that is I'm
getting my play so so you need you need
to play a move like g6 is I will be
happy to give up Oh King be 1 if you
want to play Bishop a4 it's like a
go-ahead moment like go ahead right if
you want please I'll be happy so you're
probably gonna play g6 just to make sure
that nothing happens on that side but
then we don't we get to move the rook
away exactly and then you keep it going
right the game goes on so like something
like rook e1 so you can go night deep
rip D 1 to e1 so you can go tonight to
do you want but now I tried that Bishop
f6 maneuver because booboo paper doesn't
really work anymore it just feels like
it induces b3 or well I'm not gonna play
and we can my queenside I'll just I'll
just move my rook and okay Bishop I'm
saying from White's point of view I'm
really happy about this because I could
put the knight on e3 I've got a pretty
good blockade going on in 93 there could
be a problem though because ninety three
rook on c2 that's that's very very know
this whole line you know it's funny
because I think I was among the people
who thought that Magnus withum play
double can come on today like actually
last night I said I thought it was
actually 5050 and part of the reason I
reduced the odds is because I saw a
tweet by Robert Hass where he was saying
he thought hey I mean Magnus has been
playing the Sicilian I kill probably
just keep playing the Sicilian right um
it's it's naive to think that it's like
so much less dangerous to play a double
King pawn right but I think it's also a
little bit of this like small sample
size which I'll often critique myself
that just because ye got two great
positions in the open Sicilian in a row
doesn't mean he's gonna keep getting
them and in fact now today was a day
that it turned out the other way
exactly and I think it's quite I think
it's quite early to say it to say that
you know Magnus is gonna win this game
so many people on Twitter just like so
confident in his position they're like
calling the match really if you take a
look at the incredible dis fence in the
other games it's hard to do that yeah
sure Magnus against a lesser G yeah
Abby's not collapsing that's for sure
but hold on come on Maurice help us out
here I didn't think shutting down the
position with a five and a four was in
blacks best interest am I wrong what
does this [ __ ] think about blacks play
max feel better
blacks better like what because what
what is just yeah I'm sitting here what
do I got I like that I want to know what
what are you playing
what are you playing for what's your we
don't need an engine to look at this
play what am i playing for his white
show me your next five moves if I don't
do anything I always tell this to my
students
I see your idea if I don't do anything
like actually what I tell them is make
him over said well you have to make him
over I said no no I want you to move and
I've done this on this show with you yes
of course all the time sure what are you
what are you gonna do I'm gonna do
nothing for a few moves
let me just shuffle back and forth to
see what's your best ideas and then I
will fashion what to do about your best
idea well my best idea is to move my
king time ticking away mm-hmm
reposition my rooks and most importantly
reposition the knight on f2 to the e3
square if I could get in so you want to
move your move oh yay mr. king b1 let's
start with king b1 right so you want to
move your rook move this move this rook
move this rook play Bishop d4 Knight
move this bishop bring this Knight back
here and then we unite to e3 and after
I've done all of that yes then what
I haven't activated anything I haven't
created a threat right I just feel like
I've been crew ever-so-slightly the
position of my pieces
okay so let's but let's say you've done
all those moves exactly what is your
next set of moves here of a knight here
you're hoping for a fortress yeah well
yeah then I just got my pieces on their
best squares and I'm saying I can't do
anything more so that is the kind of
stuff I don't want to hear if I'm white
right I'm going I got to make five moves
I went on at the endpoint of my fifth
move you've reached this your words work
I don't have anything to do I got a
fortress some of my best squares yes it
that's it that sounds awful right that's
like you did all that to do what any
time so now we add work what he want now
black is gonna prepare d5 right this is
what's coming all right this is the
setup for the long term and once black
hits with that move you better be
completely ready and hope that your
setup stops that exactly at the moment
now we have the move Bishop f6 I believe
has been played so a little bit of cross
circuiting on your move your Bishop d4
move when it happens
yep also don't forget who has the
protected pass pawn in the position
spatial advantage goes to who black the
forget white having space avenge no no
safe King any breaks left no breaks left
this is
off-the-menu this actually I'm thinking
about this move myself because I I just
need to open up the game so I'm keeping
it in the back of my mind somewhere I
you know this is a move that you can
play in a lot of positions of the guy's
not paying attention to crack the
position open
but the problem is H takes and unless I
have Brooks doubled on this line and
ready to sacrifice everything on g4
looks like it's not gonna be anything
special and even then maybe it won't
work for anything anything of value so
that's gone we're looking for pawn
breaks for white
they don't exist mm-hmm so in other
words with Fabi being down so much on
the clock as well 55 minutes for Magnus
23 minutes for white he's got to get in
another ten moves would probably make it
as long as this move doesn't land at any
point where it hurts that is the real
concern that white has right now right
black playing this move b5 just at the
right moment he's not worried about
Bishop a4 that he'll sack in exchange if
need be he's worried about this move b5
landing and what Magnus has done he's
played like Petrosian he's gonna like
Karpov he hasn't played like his far off
yeah he has played like tall but he's
playing like the other champions who say
you've got nothing to do right stand
there and I'm gonna hit you in the face
right and I'm gonna hit again you know
you got nothing to do okay I'm on a
punch okay maybe that one didn't land
I'm gonna try it again right right
Fabi said this after his game what was
that game where he played Bishop takes
f3 with the black pieces the last time
Magnus seconds yes
Magnus regulation white in that English
when he took on f3 and they said why did
you do that you gave the guy a clean
advantage and Fabi said I know but I
didn't just want to drift it looked like
black had easy moves to play and I
wouldn't know what to do I would drift
so I decided to just make it very clear
and going to this opposite color Bishop
ending that looked like maybe I could
make a draw and it was easier to play it
it's the critical point was easier to
play you're in this position you you
can't do anything about what black is
gonna do this is the kind of nightmare
position he does not want to see black
has all the play you're trying to
reposition your pieces to get them on
good squares and hope that when the blow
comes and you're ready yeah that is that
is a tough way to fight for the world
champ
for your life right at this moment
looking for reassurance we're all split
because in one hand as commentators and
lovers are chats we love the game I mean
in the open line Sicilians fashion
economy fascinating ideas from not only
a tactical point of view but also a
strategic point of view right that's one
of the reasons I think so many people
love the Sicilian it's not it's real
tactical strategy oh absolutely
different ideas castling on opposite
side sometimes plain we're positionally
sometimes going for the endgame it's
like every idea and chest is in the
Sicilian all right by the way you put
your knight on it's nerve-racking for
Fabi you put your knight on on a III
which I went to d1 and then to e3
correct what about putting it on g5
where it belongs in the first place
Knight h3 Knight g98 you put it on g5
like what about that as an idea at least
to make the guy think about 96 you might
take on I really don't want to take on
c5 because that Bishop look like it's
gonna laugh at me but if I don't let
your Bishop get into the game with power
that dark square Bishop and I get my
knight to e6
at least I take this Knight over this
anemic square and give it I mean your
III looks okay yes but I don't see the
potential if he plays g6 where it's
gonna go from there right you give
yourself better maybe even to go to g5
so look to go to g5 take on c5 and then
at least from g5 will be able to jump to
e6 on a good day
and by the way I get some of those g4
breaks again because I'm always again to
take on each ride use it after Bishop a4
you're always playing you're always
attacking the exchange with Bishop h5 I
think nine times out of 10 the answer is
yes to that question but a but there is
a serious rob there is a bit of problem
with that stupid five move also is gonna
come in
so the problem is taking an age five
doesn't actually start an attack at all
you need to be able to like take it with
a queen to start an attack I have a move
on movies rook to e1 okay I I mean I
understand five B's idea like I'm
thinking he wants to bring his knight
into civilization f2 is not doing
anything
III or c3 more compelling squares but I
think that was a very legitimate and
good idea to play Knight Age 3 and
Knight g5
I think fabbi when he rejected the Moon
Knight g5 earlier doesn't want to come
back to it two moves later that said
like if if you played after Bishop a4
you would've had the baby played b3 and
then we had to calculate the sacrifices
yes yeah so maybe that's maybe but maybe
he didn't like the looks of that or even
not sacrificing even just like saying
okay maybe I've made an achievement by
weakening that a12 I don't know if you
could induce white to play the move b2
b3 yeah you really want to get that in
for now of course with the rook movie do
you wanna pay for and you simply move
the rook away right there so in this
case we'll really hit nothing and it's
not like the rook is great on C - anyway
the rook which is back off the threat
and oops well you shouldn't leave this
guy hanging for the rest of the game
you're gonna have to play g6 or bishop
bishop doing an a4 and that's why I mean
he won hasn't necessarily committed 291
is my point right okay it's so try to
maneuver is Knight to g5 so let's say we
go g6 just to release the bishop to mate
b7 b5 posse now I try your knight h3
idea yeah it's definitely maurices idea
about my knight h3 to get the Knight to
e5 on a good day to get the Knight to g5
I mean yes no how do I go about trying
to exploit this opportunity mm-hmm
you know how to play as black hair yeah
piece I see how to play
yeah I mean I want to get b5 in somehow
they b5 in Queen b6 or something like
right b5 in Queen d7 Queen b7 yeah you
put your pieces over there and just be
proud right well yeah and I'm also
difficult it's not easy huh well I'm
also looking if I ever have an idea like
playing my pee on ketamine my Queen play
Queen g7 and I was also thinking that if
you could get gone to b3 then to play
Bishop to h8 and Queen g7 exactly that
you're on the long bag well you're
really happy right now I don't feel that
the rook on f8 is really being heroic so
let me put the rook on a better square
so that when you go Knight g5 and I put
the rook on e7 I'm anticipating that one
day the Knights gonna go to e6 but at
least once it does that it won't be
attacking a rook on f8 so let me play
rook a seven-night g5 rookie 7 I don't
think you want to capture this and and
remember Bishop d4 Knight e3 we were
trying earlier now the ship d4 93 you
have Bishop takes f6 91 Bishop e7 right
so you could play so this is different
yeah now you could play Bishop d4 and
provoke a trade I and I think I think
the line there is okay for white that I
just mentioned 93 Bishop f6 91 Bishop e7
Knight see - yeah right right right
right
okay my computer just really loves
that's the thing protecting the bishop
on ethics yeah so Bishop f6 could
provoke the trade of bishops for sure
so this rook e1 move by Fabi doesn't
necessarily imply that he's gonna play
the night the yuan maneuver it's more of
just like a prophylactic move so that he
doesn't have to weak in his position
with that ugly-looking and b3 move which
every dragon player knows I mean like
once you get that diagonal I mean once
once you play B three you better
beginning the ship before and let's put
it that way if you don't get Bishop
before and you'll be in big trouble and
then I'll have 93 like we looked into
the other
because I haven't maneuver my routine 7
yet let me just say the audience we are
trying to get Latimer Kramnik to join us
we don't know exactly
well the world champion Vladimir Kramnik
yes pleasure for me to be invited at
this particular moment of the matching
of the game fantastic vladimir share
your thoughts first of all specially
cough how do you like the position it
depends which position you mean it's
blacks position I like very much yeah
why it's little less are you surprised
by the way black played so far do you
think that this kind of control chess
was the best way to go because he could
have played much more sharply with ideas
like B five instead of a five and
shutting the game down yes I think that
Magnus okay he's trying to play with no
risk at all I mean he has an advantage
he had a big advantage now it's getting
smaller and smaller I can see with every
move but he is trying to be completely
safe you know that he has absolutely
zero risk and then I mean okay to try to
win it you know in a technical way but I
because I suppose he thinks that in
tiebreak he has better chances so he
just wants to avoid any stupid blunder
by himself but I agree that I'm pretty
sure he could have done much better I
mean at some point his position was
really close to be Vinick maybe even now
now I would say that it's it's still
very unpleasant for white in my opinion
very difficult to to defend but it's
kind of blocked and winning is not going
to be so I mean easy for him but frankly
I still don't like it for white at all
by the way what's your assault you have
to weigh the move a4 what's what's your
way of winning this game if you are
black what's what's the concrete plan
you see this
I heard White's feelings no but I mean
it slowly I guess you try to push b5
that is some there are some ideas you
know maybe 93 at some point even a
sneeze and some tactic some diagonal
well the main problem that white doesn't
have an idiom front of way I mean he and
he has to choose what to do for me for
instance - changing bishop so not only
for health I mean of course ideally I
would try to change the bishop from
before and put my knight on his three
and then it will be more or less okay
even so that is b5 all this cannon I
mean it's actually quite difficult to
understand what white should do maybe
Knight h3 Knight g5 but of course black
has three three play on the Queen fight
and white the white is the position it's
really dangerous especially in practical
sin and especially considering the well
not such a great time management of Fabi
today around 50 minutes for Magnus and
18 for favi and now fabio move after
Magnus has played a four gonna go for
this plan of Knight h3 to g5 well I
would say that the I mean I think Magnus
is kind of trying lazy chess a bit he's
just making kind of I mean good most
useful moose and he wants I think he
might be thinking that his position will
just improve and one day something will
you know something will come up
sometimes eggs will and maybe his right
is hard to say but also it's his play
last few moves is kind of little small
to my to my taste but it can be still
strong and it can be maybe he's right I
don't know what to say it's too
complicated position the the stakes are
so enormous lehigh you can almost
understand this aversion to risk and
burn bridges so just a lot of moves that
Magnus have been has played or
good strong moves but not necessarily
the most sharp or aggressive because
he's just he is trying to avoid losing
the World Championship on a blind if you
said yes yes I mean I mean his moves has
to good you know they're still good and
you know it's very understandable he's
now only concerned is to win the world
championship match you know the second
we think I'm sure he cares now I mean
doesn't care about playing best moves
Vinick now or in blitz Armageddon
doesn't care at all I think he just
wants to win it so he's trying to
minimize risks and trying to to get
let's say the maximum of of winning
chances for the match and I'm even I can
tell you that I'm pretty sure that he
understands very well that his moves are
not objectively the best one but I think
he knows it very well and but but he's
just doing I mean he's been very
professional as during the whole match
as now I mean maybe to someone taste
even a little too professional because
you know what I mean but so far I mean
everything is today is going I mean in
his direction obviously I mean today so
far it's really the worst possible
scenario FRB could have for this
particular game and the clock is not his
friend at all as he's down to 16 minutes
is Fabiano before the rest of his moves
and find with magnets over 50 minutes
left on the clock
Wladimir week and ask Gary this question
when you are playing that critical final
game the one that you know well is for
all the money world changers world
championship title what you did when you
defeated this bar what you did when you
defeated laco what you did when you
defeated to Paulo what do you do to
prepare for such a moment you personally
what did you do when you said okay this
is the one where I've got to bring
all my strengths as a chess player to
achieve a dream that I've had since I
was a little boy no I
it depends on the person very much you
know the different approaches my
approach was always just to forget about
it I mean I was just thinking about the
game as if I'm playing a regular game
you know that's what was my always way
of playing such games it's just okay I'm
trying to do my best and let's see what
happens you know I mean you know in such
moments especially when it's real
championship match maybe I have a
strange and a bit old-fashioned way of
seeing it but I believe it's you know
it's already not so much up to you you
know what will happen because it's very
right you might get like you might get
unlucky I mean you're not you're not in
control anymore fully in what so the
only thing which you control is is your
play is your stamina is not to get not
to blundin I mean not to get too nervous
I mean to play as well as you can at
this particular moment and the rest you
shouldn't think about it ideally because
you know anything can happen you can
plunder your opponent can blunder you
can play a trillion game or or you can
play a good game and your opponent plays
even better one I mean anything can
happen so you should just concentrate on
playing well you know and as simple as
it sounds at least this is my approach
maybe garlic has different one I don't
know but the Gary was similar Gary was
similar in his statement about just
being a challenge for him and it's
amazing to hear the great champions talk
about how relaxed more or less they were
just thinking about the game but that
said were you never you know peeing in
your pants during these days like you're
like oh my god I'm super nervous at this
moment didn't it happen to you like
during one of the games where your heart
just beating out of your chest even when
you went to the board and tried to just
lay chess no only when I was very young
when I was maybe 17 or something maybe
it could happen but not really because
you know it's a philosophical question
after all I never felt I was never
forgetting and never forget still that
it's only a game you know
it's more championship au revoir a lot
on steak but it's a game of chess you
know it's not a matter of life it's not
you know there are many things which are
more important in life than a ball
championship title you know still that
makes you feel like okay of course it is
important you really want it when you
are playing after all you know life goes
on life is much bigger than just this
game role title and that makes you
somehow maybe cooled down a bit and not
to get too nervous
but of course maybe maybe for someone he
needs another approach maybe I don't
know maybe he meets exactly though
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu get to his best I mean
so it's very individual it depends very
much on your temper on your character
even on your you know philosophical way
of seeing life so I wouldn't recommend
it to anyone I'm just telling you what I
feel when playing such games these guys
seem really cool I'm glad Amir what were
the things that you were referring to
that are more important than the World
Championship I don't know I I've got two
kids for example now family life your
health your friends do not play for
night h3 to g5 he played Queen before
what's your impression of this move I
think it's fine yeah it's I'm not sure
night actually Knight g5 was really
risky because you could really get mated
I mean he's trying to avoid to get mated
the the main the main problem I mean
just to control the inside the main
problem that you know it's quite
difficult for Blake it's easy to play
here you can make almost any move and
useful move g6 even whatever yeah and
white has to choose a plan and there is
a lot of tactics if Knight goes from F
to some 93 might come d5 you have to
watch out for the five for all sorts of
a three-year okay I see that makes it I
would say not only the position is a bit
and I would say rather unpleasant but
it's quite difficult to play for white
you really have to to control lot
of different things and that's why okay
it's not a terrible time pressure but
since the position is complicated and
deadly move which white have to make is
is quite a difficult decision
it might he might end up in a serious
time trouble
I mean I might have a feeling but first
of all he is a good fighter and also
mark knows can start to get a bit
nervous or other way around to get to to
safe you know and in both of these cases
anything can happen
speaking of which time trouble again
Jennifer I am just wanna ask what the
times are 45 to 15 is what we have 45
minutes to Magnus on move was 30 minutes
for Fabi with 10 moves to go a three two
one time edges three three two one plus
30 on the clock how significant is that
the bottom you in a position like this
one with white I'd you mentioned having
very little to do and have to worry
about all kinds of potential blistering
tactics if he makes an off move it is
very important it is the serious issue
here because okay let's say mark knows
play some useful kind of good move now
b6 whatever then again every every move
is a decision to play 91 not to play an
idea one to go tonight Ashley I mean you
cannot really move so much to be the
item but you cannot also stay because
Blake will slowly you know move all his
pieces and push b5 or something so the
decisions are not easy for white and
therefore of course Haven not much time
is his might might be a serious issue
yeah but I would say all we know so far
really things going really as as bad as
it could get you know for for Fabi today
I mean but but it doesn't mean it's
going to end badly but it's it's really
a bad day for him now I mean bad
preparation neuron plan not good play a
little time left but but he's good
fighter I mean you know and in such
moments of critical moments even
Magnus with his nurse and with his you
know stamina can can make
can make something wrong you know you're
never sure about anything if I can be so
bold as to ask you just about the
opening because as it turned out as the
players got to this position right out
of the opening with h4u in Batumi
olympiade had things yes and I have the
position after h4 could you just kind of
give us your thoughts on the opening and
this motion specifically if I remember
well my opponent played Bishop e7 which
is I actually can see that it has best
move but a6 is also very interesting
very sharp move h5 I personally
considered it as okay normal I mean yeah
it sticks a BH GBC I remember it was
very sharp and very unclear but I guess
okay I don't know why's it like two
three years ago and not with the most
powerful computers so probably now
they're telling something pretty
different but I remember here this is
for if I remember well and it was sharp
and not completely clear to me but in
any case but h4 h5 I mean frankly I was
very surprised today and and I don't I
don't want to be you know route to to
anyone but I think it's a big failure of
the team of fab' that actually he was
started to think after Bishop e3 I mean
the line is very sharp very direct so I
mean it seems to me that the move h5 was
simply not even analyzed you know and
this is a this is a very big failure
because it's a serious move in fact
black have only three reasonable moves
a6 Bishop e7 and h5 and after h5 if I
remember well I was heading for Bishop
g5 I mean my plan was Bishop g5 and in
fact I actually don't like after his
five legs position in general but I mean
okay the first first bad surprise what
the that Fabi started to think and then
I think okay I didn't like at all the f3
move at least this is not the way I was
planning to trade the position I didn't
want to play f3 at any you
at any moment right and and then of
course Rakesh to was was just too much I
mean so well somehow it's it's a kind of
mixture of not good preparation and that
Fabi okay didn't really get into the
position I mean really doesn't seem that
he analyzed it enough to get the feeling
of it and I think he made quite some
wrong decisions you know and okay so he
is ending up now with white you know
trying to serve wife and writing for for
a draw but okay I mean chances but of
course it was yeah it was I mean I can
imagine how his hope is feeling now
during a game when he went clearly to
press with Y to try to win and and and
instead he's just have to defend
unpleasant position with little time on
his clock I mean it's a difficult
feeling but but he's strong he's a
strong person so I mean I I still
believe he has chances to make a draw
even if objectively position is not a
cup of tea you know for anyone and black
did play that waiting movies you
mentioned the move g6 in that position
and Fabi continued with the move rook
from E to D one the rookie just went
from D to e 1 now it goes rely I'm
overly anyone I think his plan is to go
to ki jiye to 91 93 he just wants to
stop if he Milton idea one I guess gives
a thread of all sorts of 93 mo so he
wants to stop it but I'm okay I think
Blake should try to get simply to the
group his business like these six by
between us I rope rope I mean to try to
go for B five or maybe even a three like
at some point to create and maybe
somewhere a stable this rate actually
after we move like rookie it why it
really has a difficult choice what to do
because it might be that h3 can be a
threat already in some situation like
this denied mr. Bishop a4 you never know
so weather weather has to put green on
a3 or otherwise I mean in one day a city
can come so I would think of doing
something like oka at some point
and then and then actually to in fact
just practical way to make your opponent
sing do you want a city you don't want a
city maybe you want you know something
else and and it's yeah difficult to play
for for white disposition but I mean if
from another point of view I think if
Magnus gets too slow and white is in
time to get through to Knight to c3 it
can slowly get some kind of fortress you
know I mean I think if if Magnus wants
to win this game he needs also to start
calculated I did some Sun breaks through
some variations and which is for the
moment not really I don't have a feeling
psychologically that he wants to do it
but of course if he misses in next two
three moves he misses a good opportunity
to create concrete problems for white he
might not have them anymore in this game
that's my feeling
played by Magnus yeah um earlier Gary
Kasparov was on and he said that he
thought that there was an over 50%
chance that this game would be decisive
what's your take of course that was an
hour ago well and now what ago there was
yes chance was much higher than now but
it's do I would say I don't see any way
for white to be in this game unless
Martin simply blunders so makes a big
miscalculation but Blake definitely has
chances to win it I mean it's I would I
would say now frankly to be frankly 5050
whether it's whether Fatih manages to
hold it or not but it's quite difficult
situation for him now there's 5050
wagers well yeah a question that III
think a lot of people would like to hear
your answer for too
we've seen eleven consecutive draws
your thoughts about that is a good for
chess as a bad purchase is it just the
fact that these guys makes a few
mistakes yes no I mean but it's true
that the general level of course is very
high of both of them and also the of
course here is developing more and more
computers are really making it very
difficult not only to get an advantage
let's say this right but even to get a
game kind of you know it's it's true but
it's still possible I think that of
course you know when you to such strong
players are playing and you see lots of
drawers and everything basically one one
loss can be decisive here that's why
players are you know Haven having
tiebreak at their mind always as an
option yeah there of course I mean I
have to admit anyone would have the same
attitude that of course I'm sure that
both of them
the main motivation when they come to
play even with white is not to lose the
game
mm-hm I mean losing this is a really big
disaster even a single game okay and
then if you get a chance to win yes that
would be great but so my I I opinion is
actually already told about this idea
I've heard this idea and I quite like it
actually that you know my idea how to
make it let's say more entertaining and
without actually any problem for anyone
for chess lavas for chess players is so
think about it my my idea is to make a
tie-break before the game one and then
there is you know always somebody's
behind and somebody's ahead there is not
a simple situation never can appear in a
match that you know score is equal and
basically draw is kind of a case for
both opponents and and like this I'm
sure okay it will not make like nine
decisive games out of dwell right but I
assure you that you know there will be
there will be players whoever it will be
will be taking more risks because
somebody is always behind you know on
score yeah
and I don't see any minuses in this I
mean and also it's like kind of good
warm-up for spectators before the match
for players it's like a good warm-up
here there and another positive moment
you can be sure that the World
Championship match will be decided in
classical chess and not in Blitzer
McDonald exists yeah so the 12th game
will be the decider xi will be the
decisive one by the way we should point
out I'm sorry we should just point out
that the clock situation is getting
worse and worse and worse now 38 minutes
from Magnus 12 minutes and Counting for
Fabi he's been in a four minute think in
a situation where he's got these nine
moves to make now he won though and and
he did we have him playing room do you
want Rock a eight it's a very difficult
okay Lucas six might become in rugby six
and A three I mean he thinks how he
should settle his pieces maybe Queen a
series and B five might be coming after
Bishop d7 Ruby eight whether to try to
counter-attack it's a very difficult
decision of a white so that's why I mean
I fully understand and he needs now to
take time in this position because okay
if he is just moving around Blake will
get through cases we should be seven
rotator b6 h3 and just made so he needs
to make it's a difficult decision
important decision now so I think he
should think now I mean even if it even
if he will be long time but let's see if
he doesn't if he doesn't make something
right now he makes a mistakes it will be
too late to think after two three moves
so he needs to do it now so he is
absolutely right
when is he gonna when does he move no
matter what though because you can't
leave yourself five minutes to make the
next nine moves you better leave
yourself five minutes for nine moves and
fifteen minutes and totally lost
position
yeah when you anyway you have 30 seconds
increment and you know this the chess
player this is the position you really
need to make some important decisions
you need to think whatever time will be
left you know after that so is that
because you can sense that this is a
critical position why this position and
you're you're thinking it's gonna calm
down a little at some break for instance
if we play Queen a3 you don't have to
worry about a3 is that yeah but then you
have to worry about b5 yeah I mean they
think is that he made all useful moves
and he knew he cannot stand
he cannot just stay because Blake will
improve his position so he needs to make
a strategical decision maybe to change
the bishop at some point with bishop
before whether he moves the Knight to h3
g5 which is more trying to create
contact way-o to c3 trying to shoot he
worried about a 3 or not I mean okay
it's a very very difficult decision i I
would even frankly I'm just thinking now
maybe to play rook c3 at some point give
the rope for this tie no of course not
not now but I mean he has something to
worry about
okay six especially Bishop d7 or okay it
would be 63 I mean this very simple one
and he has to do something minutes left
good understand the world that it's a
critical moment now if he he doesn't
find the right plan he can easily just
you know I mean the his position will
can just deteriorate he needs he needs
to create something now I think it's a
critical moment and that's such an
important skill to be able to tack that
and you're just thinking that there's a
good chance if he finds the right moves
in the next couple moves the position
will calm down a little bit and he'll be
able to play more quickly yes
yeah that's the part I mean I would
probably it doesn't look so great to
play Queen h3 but I really don't like so
much this kind of always potential a
three thread maybe to put Queen on a
three even if and then roommate there
would be 291 it doesn't look great but
at least at least kind of you know and
very I would be very worried about a
three very good I mean potential idea of
phase 3 so I would probably
put my queen on a three and hasn't moved
yet the clock is ticking he's down now
at eight minutes and and worse this is
absolutely not good at all and we're
talking about all those moves Queen a
three but nine H so much to judge and it
looks like Magnus's decisions whatever
you might call them maybe could have
knocked the guy out earlier but his
decision to just keep control of the
position play with no risk and just
dominate the board is bearing fruit
I mean practical purposes Mac what's
Lobby moves
Magnus is gonna have a ton of time on
the clock to set yet another difficult
strategic question to his opponent I
mean this is this is one of those things
Vlad where you you get the guy any happy
news
sorry to blow your world away 30 years
what that's that's what we're hearing in
both reaction to this stunning I cannot
believe it I mean I hope so not because
I'm rooting for anyone but because
frankly just I don't know how to tell it
politely let me tell the first word
which I which I which comes to my mind
okay I mean it's a shameful for black to
Topher droid if it's true I mean it's
just the same absolutely
I mean he's just better with any result
any risk and how can you offer a droid I
mean this is out of any I mean questions
for me but ok I mean I don't know if
it's true
Wow I mean finally if it's true it means
that like wow I mean sexy you still got
the position up usually it goes blank
when the position goes away but
everybody is saying it's a drawer we got
a result on my screen I'm gonna tell you
there is there is no way you're playing
completely with no risk as black for the
next ten moves white is struggling to
figure out how to develop pieces where
to put them how and you can and you can
off-road rotate you might hit and after
five Nomos I mean it's just absurd I
mean it's I don't know something is
wrong with Magnus I mean he I can only
have a feeling he just cannot withhold
the pressure and I don't know I mean
it's but okay I mean I appreciate him a
lot the chess play he's a great chess
player I mean but this is not the way
you you play watching this I mean you
you have to fight I mean I mean just
frankly it's such a show in such a
weakness you know I mean okay in a
better position in decisive game with no
risk go for a draw I mean with much more
time I just don't know even if you
believe you are going to win I don't
know why because body can always win it
has chances but I mean you just cannot
do it it's and I mean I would understand
if he would be one point ahead no
feeling at all but with equal time I
mean this is absurd simply I mean if
it's very just unthinkable and and IR
and completely shocked but but it means
but it at least it means that we will
have a great exciting day of chess and
frankly I mean I can't
now after this okay I mean again nothing
personal but I would be rooting for Fabi
for sure I mean you cannot I mean this
simply shouldn't happen you cannot offer
a droid better palaces I mean you have
to be punished
you know philosophically fantastic 12
but you simply cannot do it I mean
reminds me very forcibly of a Viktor
Korchnoi left paw League is key in the
penultimate round Viktor cautionary from
a much better position offered a draw in
the very next day he was punished with a
loss and they went into overtime so I'm
completely with you I mean it's a shame
for chess it's the world champion no not
for chance I mean for chess was an
interesting game I mean for forbid not
he was defending you know it was the
worst position I mean it's I mean we had
a lot of entertainment today and
actually we are in a way like is that we
will have another day of entertainment
but as a world champion even I could say
for a challenger maybe it would be kind
of understandable but you know champion
you know you're the best player and and
you have to prove it simply especially
in the running you have to prove it I
mean you know it's you have to win a
title to try at least to win a title you
know to prove that you are better I mean
in a classical chess and you have all
chances and then you just want to steal
it in a way to win it somehow
you know maybe bleah it's maybe now
maybe flagging upon you know what I mean
it's just not right as a goal
championship has a responsibility he has
to fight has to show his a face of care
he is a fighter and mark knows he is a
fighter I mean we all know but I don't
know what's happening to him that he he
just cannot cannot you know play in this
decisive moment I mean it's very very
sad for me actually very sad it
certainly doesn't feel heroic this yeah
it's I mean in fact you know even if he
wins and I think he's two favorite but
you know this moment
I know how to say you know it's a it's a
turning point I mean it can be a turning
point of you know I don't know in your
minds you know it's I don't know how to
explain to you but you know you just
cannot do it you simply cannot do it
only of course if there is excuse your
maybe you feel really bad I don't know
that can be of course the case is you
really feeling bad something is a can i
but if everything is fine
you cannot follow it simply I mean
that's my but okay anyway who who am I
to judge and everybody has a right to
make all decisions and I may be just too
old-fashioned you know but okay I would
never do it not because of any other
reason that I would feel that you know I
cannot do it you know it's not I don't I
don't them out to myself not because of
criticism of others but I just cannot
you know I wouldn't be able to speak for
months if I would do it myself because
it's simply you know I feel like you
know I mean I okay okay it's just my
sorry for being emotional but it was
just so shocking but you know okay I
guess somebody would not agree it gives
me somebody would criticize me maybe but
okay but it's just what I sincerely
think and that's what I do thank you
you're very honest viewpoint one I think
speaking for myself for the whole panel
we share are as you are and we do hope
it's a turning point because
well maybe Magnus will regret this
decision
again thank you so much for joining us
we really appreciate having you thank
you and yes I'm really looking forward
for this tie break it's going to be
interested in any case and I have a
feeling it's not going to be as easy for
Martinez as he probably thinks I mean
Fatih is not a bad play a record player
at all I mean okay
of course Magnussen in general be
stronger but Fabi is not weak ratted
play I mean so I mean you know it can
give a half time it will not be so easy
I would say maybe 6040 for Marcus but no
more and this position winning this
position I mean I think he has more
chances at 6040 know them I mean he
should have tried today
obviously this position has so a
tie-break he is very confident we will
see we will see but in any case it will
be exciting him thank you thank you so
much break out the popcorn and thank you
very much for a special guest former
world champion about a mere kramnik for
his candor and inside on what looked
like it was shaping up to be one of the
most thrilling games of the match in the
final game as well to boot
Magnus making an incredibly strange
decision here as if which I'm sure we'll
get more insight into in the future but
for now for those of you who are Fabi
fans you've been perhaps given a
reprieve you because today he was under
the gun and now what we have though
Jennifer we have tiebreaks note coming
Wednesday Wednesday we will see a tie
break for the ultimate round
starting with for rapid games at skiing
25 plus a 10 second increment if that is
split to two we go to couplets of blitz
games repeated up to five times if
needed and then the very unlikely chance
that if all of those rapid games are
split to two and all of the Blitz game
couplets are splayed that will have an
Armageddon but we're looking at like a
1% chance for that
Longway of tiebreaks that is they go
past the rapids sorry Maurice I'm still
in shock over what I just witnessed
because I can't believe what I just
witnessed but a reprieve nonetheless for
Fabi yeah but yeah so getting the Zen
myself you know you when you think about
it as a chess player forget about when
you talked about world champion Wladimir
slugma as a world champion as a chess
player
you've got the better position with no
risk you're way ahead on you're way
ahead on the clock but I mean the guy's
got 10 less than 10 minutes on the clock
you got the better position okay we're
gonna toss in that you're the world
champion as well but why would you not
make some moves because you can always
always offer a draw now that you past
move 30 and those of us who would decry
the even the idea of a draw offer and
looking for better ways to handle that
rule you know we look at this and say
man look again one of the problems with
chess is that this idea that a draw
offer is a good thing even in rich
positions and many people said well you
got to get people to control over that
draw offer look what we got here
I mean fans paid all their money hmm you
know they're fans watching all over the
world they're potential sponsors who are
interested in putting money on chess and
at any moment the players can say we're
not interested in fighting anymore it
doesn't matter if this is a rich
position it doesn't matter if one side
by all consensus is much better we're
just not interested in fighting anymore
and you say what kind of position do you
want like what do you want so that you
can fight will give you an edge where
you're at a head on the clock your head
on the board you got very little losing
chances the guy will I will absolutely
get on his knees and thank you if you
offer amateur at any point from now
until 10 moves from now and you offer a
draw now that to me is shocking as ever
and you know Vlad had a lot of words to
say that I just can't disagree with it's
very stunning to see the game in this
way and whoever you're rooting for it
doesn't matter you rooting for
father Magnus it is gonna be on both
sides stunning to see the game in in
this way Thank You Maurice let me just
add to my two cents for a second here
Jen going back to the game just about
here just about here these parts there
would have been a hue and a cry across
the whole of the chess world if the game
had ended in a perpetual repetition a
three time repetition like this
everybody would have decried that draw
in the same man Bobby would have been
definitely criticized maybe maybe the
draw offer absolutely I think so because
there's an explanation at least for the
repetition a position you could say I'm
totally caught out of my preparation
I've already burnt like 30 minutes in
the clock I've got I don't I don't
actually think that I'm crunching the
math and I actually think it's a
negative decision for me to go forward
exact especially if for instance he
thought an extra 10 or 15 minutes most
people would not agree with the decision
but the written we see a logical
explanation where is this unless we know
something about Magnus's health and give
Michael I gotta go play and this you
better be but even I mean I played sick
myself and we all have played weight and
you know how it feels when you're sick
it's it's gotta be something really
harsh there's got to be an external
explanation for why the world champion
had a better position of more time on
the clock clearly caught his opponent in
preparation and decided that he did not
want to see this position anymore let us
just hope nothing serious happened in
his family is something that made it
very difficult for him to even sit at
the board that's all it's not something
like that that Hirai and he might
provide us with that explanation if he
wishes to share what's happening in his
personal life but let's just sincerely
hope that it's not that and I'm very
worried in fact for him that it's
something like that because not the
Magnus we know would not in how much in
many years take a draw from this
position when he knows he'll crush we've
seen magnets take not taken to raw in a
sink filled coffee remember I do listen
in the same field cup he's down a pawn
and he might have some compensation and
he would win the tournament with a draw
and he said no thank you
so to see him that does assign for us
that he was going to become world
champion we saw that we said it's not
electric yeah this guy's a boss this is
the exact opposite of that it's not like
his character to do such a thing so I'm
going to assume I would have to believe
that something else very serious is
going on and let's hope it's not the
case but that is concerning I mean
looking at his face in the pictures that
I seem to day I don't I mean obviously
you had that a soccer accident right
indeed the very puzzling and he did
offer to the draw right I so move 30
exactly he offered the draw and the Fabi
with land except of course Bobby
wouldn't offer drawn that's 331 actually
okay it was right Bobby would never
offer a drawn that situation because he
would assume better we get turned out of
course worst addition worth clock that
we just never happened it insulting to
Magnus oh well just its bladder heir
said
he's not even sure if Magnus was a point
ahead we see it we've seen Magnus be
ahead like we said to the sing folk up
right here in this building that we
really we're transmitting from so we
seem to be up would win the whole
tournament would pocket seventy granite
with with just a draw a draw was offered
to him by Levon Aronian in that game and
Magnus said you know I'm just gonna keep
playing anyway because right I don't
really see myself losing so why not just
keep playing and you and I were just
sitting back in awe this guy's a boss
the guy just basically said I'm giving
you the tournament you're the king and
he said no I already know I'm the king
you don't need to give me any gifts I'm
gonna beat you and he went about it and
beat the guy and show just how dominant
he was and then went on to win the title
a couple of months later against Einon
for the first time and so he definitely
has shown time and time again that he's
a great champion this if there is no
real explanation other than he wanted to
get to wrap it that's his only
explanation this is gonna be a stain on
him yeah no way there's people are gonna
criticize him immensely you might say I
don't care about you I made my decision
but it will absolutely be a stain on him
at this position he decided to stop
playing just too strange to take a good
position with more time on the clock for
the world title and you decide to bail
out into the uncertainty of a rapid
match I mean that's I use that confident
we that there is a postgame press
conference going on right now in London
we have some of our friends over in
London including Tony rich and Marcus
who will be moderating and reporting on
this to us because as Maurice is
hypothesized that could be a very
serious personal upset we hope that's
not the case for Magnus because
otherwise you're absolutely right this
will be a stain on his extraordinary
record of success I mean
been a great great world champion and to
offer a draw in a much superior position
with mm but I'm on the clock
safe King it boggles the imagination why
he would offer a drum yeah let's hope
what just whatever the explanation is
you cannot speak for how difficult it
might be to play on a certain
circumstances people get affected in
different ways we've seen people in life
competitors from other sports have deep
personal upsets in their family whether
it's a car accident for a wife a brother
gets killed in a drive-by shooting I'm
just thinking of things that I've seen
over the years and a player had to go to
a funeral off a family friend or family
member and then have to come back and
actually play under those circumstances
with a heavy heart sorry Maurice I just
have to interrupt you to say that the
feedback that we've gotten Jennifer
Magnus did not think he was much better
today yeah he didn't think his edge was
as great as we perceived it to begin
with second he he really just wanted to
get into the tiebreak nation I guess you
didn't even picture himself winning
today and that he was hoping just for
the getting into the playoffs and
somehow he didn't think that his
position was a lot better yeah he was
just trying to shut it down and take
away the fact that we're getting that he
was just trying to shut and I'm here I
should take no yes I'm hearing - he said
from what I'm hearing I obviously just
wasn't gonna go for it today
he just didn't want to go for that and
he's and he's playing just like he
planned it was to just get a draw and
walk out the way he did in New York when
he plays with the white piece against
Kuryakin in the last round in the last
game game 12 and took 35 minutes on the
clock the shortest game in world
championship history by time he spent 35
minutes shut it all down and he said I
like this formula I'm going now to play
the tiebreak so he's not he was not
looking to win today despite getting a
great opening position a great
opportunity he just said I was just not
gonna go for it
and he's happy with what happened that I
will say now pretty stunning and when
somebody we just got that Peter dockers
asked a question to Magnus at the very
end but you were much better and Magnus
said I don't care I don't care and said
I had a very I have very good chances in
the playoffs well obviously he there's
no doubt in my mind that he doesn't
believe with Kramnik odds of 6040 right
I mean he must think it's it's like wait
980 20 in order even higher because I
mean you got a figure that he looked at
that position with kind of tiebreak
coloured glasses and was kind of
convincing himself that you know if I go
for these b5 a 30 ideas there's a little
shadow of a risk where maybe I win a
little bit but there was like some
winning chances for right I mean I can
only speculate my right might have
thought that in order he didn't feel
like calculating I think kramnik
actually came on that point and he said
it seems like Magnus isn't playing
today's game to calculate you know and I
couldn't switch that off in his head he
couldn't switch it on rather to start
calculating and trying to win the game
when he had this plan of action thinking
was gonna be a little worse he was
thinking who's gonna be a little worse
he's gonna be fighting for the draw
somehow I mean I don't know it's so
weird though because he also played the
session of Cobb which is like the
sharpest include a really sharp line in
it yeah nothing's adding up I am very
very confused but once again we will be
back we'll be back Wednesday I think the
starting time because I may be on our
website I think the thing the reason we
were confused about that because we
thought that it is the same indeed 9
a.m. 10 a.m. an East Coast
at first we were confused about that
because it looks like it's gonna be a
very long process because the votes for
rap before rap is and
and the Blitz thereafter right even with
brakes even with even if we just go the
rapids with the short break in between
that's that could be five hours but the
reason is that the the closing ceremony
I think is gonna be rescheduled for
Thursday okay so that's probably why it
was always scheduled for the next day it
was in the regulations anyway that it
would be the day after I mean stated in
the regulations the day after the match
ends okay so we're two days after yeah
so that's already a done deal I mean I
got to tell you my Reese and final
thoughts please I will have no I will
have no final thoughts I would just have
this one right now I'm just gonna spit
something out okay cause frankly I'm so
shocked I'm so flabbergasted I I can't I
can't even completely understand
Magnus's statements I get what he was
after but it just feels like a great
champion like he has proven to be for
him to say that this was what his whole
strategy was win the match win the match
win the match I think there's gonna be a
lot of disappointed hearts all around
the world saying even Bobbi fans was
thinking this game should keep going
this game should be a game that's
probably defend to prove himself in this
situation but for you to just say shut
it down all the fans of chess will look
and say this is this is really this is
not chess there's what we call chess
this is something else and you know it's
kind of interesting if if this was how
even had tied the match and retained the
title like this like if there were no
tie breaks I think you'd say you also be
concerned like this is how it works you
know you can't win so the 12 draws by
the way never in the history of the
World Championship ever as it happened
that the players haven't won at least
two games so in a match like a one side
and one side at least and we saw that
happen in the last match two wins select
Alaska selector also featured two wins
in a 10 game match to see no wins at all
in a world championship match in the
classical portion is now affirmed as the
worst you can have you can't break that
record
because they drew all the games in them
in the classical portion so that is one
dubious record that they will hold so
you know I will I will obviously be
babbling for a long time we will be
talking about this one for hours if not
the next couple of days trying to
understand what we saw today but not a
great thing to happen for chess no an
indeed Magnus was also asked that in the
press conference and again he said I
don't care I mean well I guess I guess
that's pretty clear I mean he he
obviously in some sense must have
believed that what he was doing was
likely to give himself the world
championship match like like he he
obviously has a very very high
estimation of his chances in the
playoffs and underestimated this
position for whatever reason and at the
board that was his thought I mean I
think he was trying to win the world
championship in a way that nobody agrees
with but then you know I can understand
why obviously when a reporter asked him
do you care about how this looks for the
mainstream and the pop is already a
chess wasn't it's pretty clear his
answer it's gonna be now otherwise he
wouldn't do it
of course the way I see it very clear
damaging his very very great and
deservedly great reputation damaging for
his career damaging for clear do not
believe okay but here's my question the
only thing in magnate's his defense I'll
say is maybe do you believe him that he
doesn't think blacks that that he'd at
the board he didn't think he didn't
think black was that much better here I
mean because that's the key question
like do you believe him he says that he
doesn't think black is that much better
he doesn't it's not Bennet I think about
the case and it's not so bad cuz he just
thought he wasn't that much better and
then but then white and offer to draw
maybe because he was ahead in the clock
I mean he it was anything clear in his
mind he was better than even that he was
that much better so actually maybe he
thought his only advantage was on the
clock and therefore I think it kind of
the decision isn't that irrational sorry
it's not like he's getting upset at the
people maybe he's getting upset at
people who think it's obvious that black
is much better when
being the world champion didn't think it
was obvious but why do you offer a
drawing the guy only has nine minutes on
the clock you could offer a draw nine
minutes from that world nine moves from
now when you get to move 40 if you're
not that much better because you really
wanted a type even if you're equal what
what do what do you lose even if you
really want the tiebreaker I'll give you
that you really want the tiebreak you
you're gonna get the tiebreak whenever
you want because the guy unless you
think you're gonna be all played from
this position because he thinks with men
what Kramnik was saying that the
Carmichael's did love the position for
black but he thinks that right now but
somehow something's gonna happen and
that the character of the position might
change and potentially that could change
against him I guess that's what he's
thinking I mean unless he actually
thought he was better but just as like I
don't feel like dealing with calculating
and just said something different in the
press conference but if he literally
doesn't think blacks better than his
decision makes sense of course everybody
everybody's position with engines so
everybody thinks blacks much better what
were you talking about we're not look we
don't need to look at the position with
agents to know what's happening I mean
you would think right but then on the
other hand if the world champion says
that he thinks black wasn't better
usually think everybody's on the
collective delusion their white has no
no play whatsoever in this was a
champion the world champion Magnus
Carlsen says okay maybe I'm slightly
better but maybe I'm not and he and
Jennifer say if you accept if you take
Magnus at his word then his decision to
offer a draw is perfectly reasonable
yeah yeah no it is puzzling why he
didn't think that considering every top
Grandmaster I would have thought blacks
better without even yeah I want to ask
you that you have an equal position on
the board right it's equal right your
opponent's got nine minutes left you've
got thirty five minutes left
right it's equal you look at the boy you
say I'm not much better or maybe a maybe
is equal okay it's equal but it's got
pieces on the board
do you offer a draw now because oh
because I'm trying to exploit the guys
clock
I mean every competitor I've watched
Magnus was my competitive edge the clock
is an edge as well so you've got that in
your pocket you say let me make a few
moves right let me see what he does in
the next couple of moves because we know
when players are in time to forget the
board he raced the board what he did
with Kuryakin in 2016 what's kind of
surprising to me is that he didn't think
black was better here and I wonder if
that's where the nurse came in that
somehow is brain I don't know wait a
minute in such a draw mode yeah we can't
even and your get to it I don't senior
Math League oh I think most players who
have played chess for a while just see
this position in light black so it's
it's really bizarre that if you take
that at face value he didn't think he
was better that is the mystery to me I'm
saying
I'm also shocked I'm giving you the the
fact that he thinks a position is equal
you're you asked you said maybe he
thought otherwise
maybe we're you know whatever so I'm
giving you that of course we're all
saying this position is better for black
but that's you know I'm giving you that
let's say let's pretend that that
reality is not real like right you know
that exactly that in fact we're wrong
the engines are wrong promise wrong
everybody's wrong Kary Mullis is right
yeah okay so let's assume that we're
gonna give him all that to the argument
right we're gonna say yes he's right
we're wrong let's give him that right or
nothing he's right that he thought he
was right I know he said he thought he
was right but let's let's even say he
was right he's not much better let's
even give him that the last game you
have a big edge on the clock you're up
45 he did not have that versus versus
kuryakin no versus car yeah and he
walked in and said that was weird okay
so that was weird too but this one you
get the Pizitz um thing let's say you
didn't get the position which we think
you got
but listen you didn't get the position
let's say you got what you have on the
clock 10 minutes the guys at 10 minutes
the guys at 10 minutes could I say that
again he's got to make 10 moves
you've got 30 plus minutes I mean I had
that kind of situation before I'm when I
have that situation I go like this
I'm not moving for the next five minutes
yeah I want him to suffer I'm gonna come
up with my most nefarious looking plan I
can come up with something strong that
he has to spend another two minutes I
want his hands shaking I want his heart
beating fast I wanted to feel all that
and if we make a draw in five moves six
moves eight moves ten moves so be it you
did it man congratulations you're a hero
let's go on and play the tiebreak but if
I've got that you know how hard it is
just to get that for free right I got
you in under ten minutes with ten moves
to go and I and I have that and I got 30
plus minutes why mile for you it's wrong
I could win right now I don't have to
wait another day in other two days I
could win that was surprising to my
recent talking about his competitive
juices that's what he's talking about
there and every chess grandmaster in the
world knows what Trump's they've got in
their pocket and when the clock is so
much in your favor you don't you know
when your hearts beating if your clock
is down and you know the other side of
the shoe when you got all the time I
mean it's it's strange time for the
clock now he's saying I'm playing on the
clock right now with my bowling rapid
yeah on the clock right where I'm better
when I'm playing quickly where I'm gonna
play this guy 25 to 25 when I had where
I think I can beat him 25 to 25 we're
now actually had him at 35 to 10 it's
just that the best player in the world
could I honestly I guess the most
shocking part of it to me is that the
best player in the world could not think
that black is better here I bet that's
like mind-blowing to me it's like this
cognitive delusion type thing where
everybody on the sidelines even if
they're you know 2,100 2,000 I mean way
lower than that in fact will be like
yeah of course I love black here how can
the world champion it's it's crazy to me
right it's a perfect confirmation bias
yeah yes he wanted one thing you
he's made himself see something that
confirmed what he wanted exact what he
wanted to play on Wednesday that's what
he wanted you don't want to get hurt I
want to lose I want to get it wrong I'm
gonna play the tiebreak in a situation
where I get four games this guy is not
gonna hang with me I'm better than him
that's what my chances are oh this thing
right here it doesn't look like I'm much
better I know any serious chess player
who studied the strategy of the game
who's looked at soul men's books
nimzowitsch his books I think like
anybody who's a student of the game
likes black hair of course so for me
it's just I'm just so stunned by it all
that I really at a loss of words because
again when you just you know you you've
seen the play up to this moment and it
was clear that this was dictating I mean
again just look at White's last four
moves I wanted to say okay it was
something like hold on just a second
sorry sorry not last foremost okay this
one right here rook e1 Queen goes back
to where it was
rook back to do you want
wait a minute of later leave an
impression why this making waiting moves
and doing nothing you and yeah please
show me because I told you if you make
moves please show me how you're gonna
beat me with white well show me your
nerves young several moves I'm sure
gonna make that make me say ooh meantime
I'm black I'm trying I got a three
coming right a three remember we said a
three might show up on the board well
they're probably pointed out rook a six
to be six is another plan he's efficient
87 and rook b8 with the threat of b5 is
another plan I mean it's all day long
you're taking his guy to school right I
mean Vladimir was even pointing out that
he would be very afraid of lines where's
the route hold on I actually did it
wrong I apologize right here he was
saying that he would be afraid of lines
where the rook comes to b6 the night the
RIP comes to a6
and there was these sacrifices of knight
takes b3 that he would be even
frightened to see that he won't want to
you need another movie I understand I
understand Bishop d7 yeah right if you
have visual d7 he made the guy make a
random move right like our were few
wrecker Rocky one maybe yeah now Knight
b3 comes with real force because well
again guys I mean an amazing 12 game
match the likes of which we've never
seen before all 12 games were drawn
amazing is your word astonish done but
the fit that the completion this final
game will leave a sour taste a bitter
taste in our mouths for years to come I
mean it will just the final game what
about game 11 I like so much about this
I like many many things about this match
then I understand but game 11 it did try
to give a bra is connected to this game
right the Petroff would see for trading
madness just went Queen creating a d5
simplified shops ecology six two games
that ended this match alright we weren't
happy about yesterday as people who are
kind of like in the middle and the fence
undecided as we say you know it's pretty
easy to root for poppy now easier than
ever
well I will say that before the match it
was always the fear the outside chance
of a tiebreaker where we all felt
rightly so that happy would be a severe
that's not severe in my book that's Oh
6040 I don't know it's a I think I think
it's probably worse well well Magnus
certainly thinks so and we'll find out
who's right on Wednesday November 28th
as we follow the tiebreak for all the
marbles in the World Championship and
crown a new Chevy or retain Magnus with
champions
right I'm gonna want to miss it it's at
Wednesday a 9 a.m. here in st. Louis at
10 a.m. in the East Coast
I'm Jennifer Shahaji signing off with
Yasser Sara Juan and Maurice Ashley as
our wait for a world champion continues
thank you for joining us
[Music]
[Music]